WILDLIFE.
TUESDAY APRIL TENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM ON US ARE.
.
COMMITTEE SECRETARY AT DISTANCE
GENTLEMEN WELCOME TO WATER PARKS
ONTO MORNING AND WELCOME GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS I'M
THINKING FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO.
THE GOAL OF WHICH IS TO MAKE OUR
STATE PARKS MORE PET FRIENDLY
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S PET OWNERS.
PETS ARE BEYOND ON MOST HIKING
AND WALKING TRAILS IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS.
THAT MEANS MANY FAMILIES APART
FROM VISITING CALIFORNIAS PARKS
BECAUSE THEY CHOOSE TO VACATION
WITH THEIR PETS.
THESE FAMILIES MUST WRECK RATE
IN OTHER PARKS OR SPEND THEIR
HARD EARNED MONEY BOARDING THEIR
PAT'S IF THEY SIMPLY OPT TO GO
OFFERED. BY OUR BEAUTIFUL VAST
PARK SYSTEM.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO WOULD
SHIFT CALIFORNIA STATE PARK PET
POLICY.
RETURNS ABOUT TO BECOME MORE PET
FRIENDLY AND ENABLE MORE
FAMILIES TO VISIT OUR STATE
PARKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ME RIGHT OUT.
REALLY MOTION THERE'S A SECOND.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
IN WHICH IS SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE NO ONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MANY MEMBERS.
SO WE DO OF YES.
I IF I GET TO ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION AYE DOES THE BILL
AFFECT THE STATE BEACHES WITHIN
THE STATE PARKS.
YEAH I'M YES TO ASSEMBLYMAN
HARPER HE AND I HAVE HAD A
DISCUSSION I'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT.
I WILL BE AMENDING THE BILL TO
ALLOW.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE EVEN BANNED A DOC'S
PRESENCE ON STATE BEACHES IF SO
CHOSEN.
YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ONE ELSE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TO PUT HELP ONE MORE QUESTION OR
SAW MYSELF FAR.
A THIS IS A GOOD IDEA HOWEVER
WHEN OUT TALKS OUT AND OUT I
THINK OF FROM THE BEGINNING IT.
THAT YEAH THERE WERE A BAND
THAT YOU TO MAYBE.
IN ON THE RECENT SO ENOUGH WITH
THE TRAPPINGS OF THINGS LIKE
THAT AS THE ANY PROFESSION NOW
HOW WE CAN NOW. I HAVE THE
THOUGHT WANNA SO BE RESPONSIBLE
TO CLEAN UP. IN OUR AFTER DOGS
FOR QUORUM NOW.
CLOSING NOT FULLY COMMENTS I'VE
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE UP
WE'LL HAVE TO THE.
WHAT WILL LEAVE THE CALL OPEN
ARMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
WE HAVE.
.
ANY OTHER AUTHORS.
SURE.
PRESENT.
GOING TO GOODNESS GOV LIKE
BUT I THINK ISN'T AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY
SEVEN.
WHICH COULD CREATE A WATER
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY.
HAVE.
IN THE OROVILLE AREA.
AS YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY OR THOSE
AT A LOT OF ATTENTION BECAUSE OF
THE.
THE DAMN BUT.
HE ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT OF THIS
IS THE AREA WHERE.
.
MOST OF THE WATER IS COLLECTED
FOR PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY
TWENTY SIX MILLION PEOPLE. ARE
RELY ON THE WATER OUT OF OR
VILLAINOUS.
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN IMPROVE
OUR INNOVATION.
AND CONSERVATION TECHNOLOGY.
WITH WATER. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO THIS IS TO CREATE
A A WATER TECHNOLOGY HUB AND THE
OROVILLE AREA WHERE THERE WOULD
BE TAX INCENTIVES TO CREATE. NEW
WATER.
TECHNOLOGY CONSERVATION.
BUSINESSES.
TIME.
AND SO.
ME I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP ON ON THINGS THAT WE.
IT WE ALREADY HAVE DONE ACTUALLY
HAD OF MY DISTRICT.
.
A YOUNG MAN ACTUALLY OUT OF THE
NAVAL ACADEMY.
OF FROM THE CHICO AREA WHO HAD.
DEVELOP A NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT
TAKES DIRTY WATER AND MAKES IN
THE CLEAN WATER AND I ACTUALLY
TAKES INTO AND EVEN SALT WATER
MAKES INTO CLEAN WATER USING.
LESS ENERGY NOW THAT TECHNOLOGY
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT. AND IT'S
NOT BE A TOTALLY READY FOR.
MASS PRODUCTION YEAH.
BUT HE ENDED UP TAKING THAT
BUSINESS AND IDEA TO TEXAS.
JUST BECAUSE OF THE BETTER.
INCENTIVES THAT HE COULD GET
THERE TO TO START UP THAT.
THIS IDEA SO.
I'D RATHER KEEP THOSE
INNOVATORS HERE. AND USE THAT
TECHNOLOGY FOR CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO BENEFIT OUR ECONOMY AND SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS.
AND I WOULD YOU KNOW ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK UP IN
FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE.
FROM THE AUDIENCE.
AGAINST ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM YOUR COMMITTEE.
AND WE WE DO HAVE SOME
AMENDMENTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO MISTER CELIS
QUESTION.
LARGE GRASS OUT THERE FUSE HE
MAKES OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT YES I AM
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
HIS QUESTION ALSO THAT EARLIER.
OKAY USER THE WISHES OF THE
COMMITTEES ARE MOTION.
I HAVE A QUESTION YES.
WELL WHY ARE YOU LIMITING TO OUR
ORGAN AREA.
ONLY.
YOU KNOW REALLY THE WHY I'M
FOCUSING ON THAT BECAUSE THAT IS
ACTUALLY WHERE MOST OF OUR WATER
IS COLLECTED AND STORED IN IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO IT SEEMED LIKE AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE YOU KNOW THESE
TECHNOLOGIES CAN THEN BE.
AND OTHER DEVELOPED THEIR CAN
THEN BE BROUGHT OUT INTO THE
SYSTEM YOU KNOW THERE'S ALSO THE
ABILITY TO TEST.
YOU KNOW THINGS I THINK A LOT
MORE EASILY.
IN THE IN THE OROVILLE AREA
WHERE WE HAVE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER THINGS
IN PLACE.
SO THAT WAS KIND OF THE IMPETUS
BEHIND IT.
IN THE WINTER TALK ABOUT THE TAX
CREDIT THOUGHT.
IT. IS. IT IS SAID THEN TIE UP
COSTS OF DEVELOPMENT THE WARRIOR
A CERTAIN PORTION OF HAD THE. DO
YOU KNOW.
WHAT IT WAS SWISS
SPECIFICALLY YOU ARE SUGGESTING?
IT WOULD REALLY JUST BE A TAX
CREDIT FOR ACTUALLY EMPLOYEE
WAGES SO IF YOU START.
A BUSINESS THERE YOU GET A FIFTY
PERCENT NE. TAX CREDIT FOR A
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEE THAT'S HIRED
IN THE IN WATER TECHNOLOGY.
SO THE BUSINESS WILL GET A TAX
CREDIT ON THEIR EMPLOYEES.
AND THAN THAT IT DECREASES OVER
TIME BUT IT KIND OF GIVES IN
THAT INITIAL. INCENTIVES
AFTER THEIR STARTUP.
THANK YOU.
ALREADY WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MATHIS SECOND BY MISTER.
HARPER.
AND THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I DO HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
SEVEN.
NOT YET.
OKAY WE DON'T.
SO WE GOT A.
SET UP A QUORUM AND THEN WILL
TAKE ACTION ON THE BILL.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OR IMMENSELY.
YEAH.
DID.
SO ALL.
WOULDN'T IT WILL TAKE A VOTE ON
THIS ONE
SO THAT'S EXACTLY HOW ACTUAL.
FOR LIVING.
QUORUM.
NO WILL CALL QUESTION ON.
YOU GALLAGHER IS ITEM.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
DISASTER I'VE OF MIDDLEMAN
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
LAST FALL BROKEN.
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
SEE I.
GALLAGHER DIE GALLAGHER OF THE
PIPE.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE. CARILLO.
MMHM.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER.
KALRA.
LEVINE I'VE LEVINE AYE MATHIS
OUR MATHIS AYE. RUBIO.
SOLIS.
SOLIS I WOULD.
AND.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE
OVERALL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. COULD WE.
TAKE.
INACTION ON THE BEAT SEVENTEEN
SIXTY TWO WHICH IS A STEINORTH
BILL. THERE WAS A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADE.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE. GARCIA AYE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
I BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI NAY AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU AYE. FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE HARPER.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I RUBIO. IS.
RUBIO AYE.
SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD.
OKAY WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN ALSO
FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ON SOME
INPUT.
TWENTY FIFTY THREE.
MORNING WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
THANK YOU ALSO COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE.
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS YOU MAY OF
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO.
.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO HOW TO PUT TO
US SOME OF THESE THINGS INTO THE
BILL. OUR BUT WILL BE LOOKING AT
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO THANK
YOU AGAIN STAFF.
AND CHAIR.
L. A. B. TWENTY FIFTY THREE
DIRECTIONS STATE WATER BOARD TO
ESTABLISH SHE FESTS
FRESH WATER AND S. DURING.
HARMFUL ALGAL.
BLOOM PROGRAM TO COORDINATE THE
ACTIONS NECESSARY.
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXINS PRODUCED
BY THESE BLOOMS.
ALGERIAN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF
MANY ECO SYSTEMS.
HOWEVER CERTAIN TYPES OF ALGAE
PRODUCE TOXINS INCLUDING LIVER
AND NORA TOXIC.
THESE TOXINS HAVE MADE CHILDREN
WHO PLAYING BLOOMS POLLUTED
WATER.
SEC
AND HAVE DIRECTLY. BEEN LINKED
TO THE DEATH OF PETS AND SEA
OTTERS.
TOXIC ALGAL BLOOMS USED TO OCCUR
PRIMARILY IN THE SUMMER MONTHS.
HOWEVER DUE TO THE WARMING
CLIMATE THEY'VE INCREASINGLY
FLOURISHED YEAR ROUND.
IN FACT THE NUMBER OF REPORTED
FRESHWATER TOXIC ALGA BLOOM
SHEERLY DOUBLED.
ARE IN THE LAST YEAR.
MULTIPLE BODIES OF WATER
CURRENTLY IMPAIRED INCLUDING
LIKE SHOULD BOW IN MY DISTRICT.
ARE THE MULTI YEAR BLOOM AT LAKE
SHAPIRO HAS POISONING CAL AT
LEAST THREE PET DOGS WHO DRANK
OR SWIM IN THE WATER.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON
THIS MEASURE ARE MAPPED.
GROWLED THE CHIEF STEWARD THE
CHIEF OF STEWARDSHIP IN THE EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARKS DISTRICT AND
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT.
AND MEMBERS.
RETURN MEMBERS UP MY NAME'S
JENNIFER WILLIAMS I'M WITH THE
EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
DISTRICTS.
EVEN PROVIDES DRINKING WATER TO
ONE PART ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
CUSTOMERS AND ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY OUTH.
WE OPERATE SEVEN RESERVOIRS
USED FOR WATER SUPPLY FIVE OF
WHICH ARE OPEN FOR OUR PUBLIC
RECREATION. AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE
TODAY. ALGAL BLOOMS ARE NATURAL
PHENOMENON AND WHILE NOT ALL
ALGAL BLOOMS ARE HARMFUL SOMEHOW
GOLDBLUM'S MAY CONTAIN TOXINS
AND IT IS SOMEWHAT UNCLEAR WHAT
TRIGGERS THE PRODUCTION OF
TOXINS.
AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE WOULD
PROMOTE THE PROTECTION OF WATER
QUALITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
AS A DOCTOR COURT STATED M. IT
WOULD FORMALIZE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD'S AYE
ROLE IN COORDINATING A STATEWIDE
RESPONSE TO ADDRESSING HARMFUL
ALGAL BLOOMS.
AND I AS I MENTIONED WE WE'VE TO
THE SPAM I'VE DOES HAVE SEVEN
RESERVOIRS AND IN RECENT YEARS
WE HAVE SEEN.
A FEW ALGAL BLOOMS IN SOME OF
OUR RESERVOIRS THOUGH HARMFUL
ALGAL BLOOMS ARE RARE IN OUR
DRINKING WATER RESERVOIRS. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT.
THE QUALITY OF THE DRINKING
WATER OUR CUSTOMERS ULTIMATELY
RECEIVE HAS NOT BEEN IMPACTED BY
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS. BY.
WE DO HAVE A REGULAR MONITORING
PROGRAM AND WHEN THERE IS AN
ALCOHOL BLOOM AS THERE HAS BEEN
THAT LIKES ABOUT WHICH IS ONE OF
OUR EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER
SUPPLY RESERVOIRS.
AND THEN THERE WAS AN
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENTS OF AYE
PAT'S BEING POISONED THERE. WE
WORKED DIRECTLY AND WITH OUR
RECREATION SERVICE PARTNERS EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT TO
INVESTIGATE THE BLOOM TEST.
AND MONITOR WATER QUALITY WORK
TO MITIGATE THE BLOOM AND
PROMOTE COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIREMENTS BANNING BODILY
CONTACT.
I'M ALL THAT BEING SAID WE THINK
THAT AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THE STATE
UNDERTAKES RESEARCH AND DATA
COLLECTION NEEDED. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CAUSES AND
EFFECTS OF HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS
AND IMPROVE THE ABILITY TO
PROTECT SAM TO BETTER PROTECT
AND MANAGE ALGAL BLOOMS WHICH
WILL HOPEFULLY I ULTIMATELY HELP
PROVIDE WATER PROVIDERS SUCH AS
EAST BAY MIND.
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS ALGAL
BLOOMS AND INCLUDING THOSE THAT
ARE HARMFUL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SPEAKER.
GIVE THEM A MAD CRAWL IN THE
CHIEF OF SECURITY FOR THE
SPIRITUAL PARK DISTRICT
AND I OVERSEE OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS A
DISTRICT.
AND PRIMARILY THE WATER QUALITY
AND WILDLIFE PROGRAMS.
THE EAST REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
WE OPERATE OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRES IN ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. IN EAST BAY
OF THOSE SAMPLES KOBE.
WE SERVE OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION VISITORS A YEAR FROM
THROUGH THE REGION AND WE ALSO
HAVE NINE.
RESERVOIRS AND LAKES THAT WE
OPERATE FOR A RECREATIONAL.
VALUES AND AND NINE OF THOSE
RESERVOIRS THAT WE OPERATE.
ABOUT FIVE OF THEM ALLOW BODY
CONTACT WATER RECREATION I WHICH
IS SWIMMING.
WE ALSO ALLOW FISHING IN AND
ALL NINE OF THOSE RESERVOIRS AND
ALSO ALLOW OR KAYAKING IN THE
RESERVOIRS AND OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF CHALLENGES WITH BLUE GREEN
ALGAE BLOOMS WE'VE HAD BLOOMS.
OF FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS BUT THE
FIRST TOXIC BLOOM WE HAD WAS IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND THAT RESULTED IN THE CLOSURE
OF ONE OF OUR LAKES AND AROUND
THAT SAME TIME THAT.
THAT'S TIME WE HAD A DOG THREE
DOG BEST THAT LECTURE ABOUT
WHERE THE TIME. AND THAT WAS
DESPITE.
SIGNAGE NOTIFICATION TO THE
PUBLIC AND TESTING WE WERE
DOING.
BUT DESPITE THAT NOTIFICATION
WITH THE PEOPLE STILL OUT ME AND
GOT TO THE EDGE OF THE WATER IN
AND AND UNFORTUNATELY.
WE HAD THESE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES SO WE REALLY HAD TO
STEP UP OUR MONITORING PROGRAM I
DO A LOT MORE MONITORING A
WEEKLY AND ALSO TO TRAIN OUR
STAFF TO BILL TO SEE.
BLOOMS AND REPORT THEM.
A AND DO ALL THE TESTING AND
NOTIFICATION NOW ALL THIS IS
BEEN POSSIBLE BY USING NATIONAL
GUIDANCE AND A WORK WITH THE
STATE AGENCIES.
BUT OFTEN OF THEIR TIME IS
LIMITED AND THE AN EFFORT
DISEASE USING STUDIES FROM OTHER
AREAS AND THIS TASK FORCE WOULD
BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN
COORDINATING A STATEWIDE
EFFORTS.
THERE'S A VERY QUALIFIED TAFF
AT THE WATER BOARD AND AT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
RIGHT NOW THE EFFORTS AREN'T
COORDINATED ON A STATEWIDE BASIS
AND. ARE WE WOULD BE A STRONG
PARTNER IN THAT AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THOSE AGENCIES BUT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE.
THIS EFFORTS COORDINATED UP ON
A STATEWIDE BASIS BUT OF THE
RESEARCH THAT'S GOING AND HOW TO
TREAT THESE BLOOMS THE HAD
REDUCE TOXIN FORMATION IS. JUST
BEING DEVELOPED AND WOULD LIKE
THE STATE REALLY BECOME A
LEADER.
IT IN THIS EFFORT TO COORDINATE
RESEARCH AT THE STATE LEVEL AND.
DATA AND BETTER HELP DEVELOP
PROGRAMS FOR NOTIFICATION AND
AND STOPPING THESE TOXIC BLOOMS.
IT'S THAT RECREATIONAL DIVIDE
IS ESSENTIAL TO THE BAY AREA AND
A VERY IMPORTANT.
TO THAT THE AND AND THE TOWNS
ARE FACING ARE BEING EXPERIENCED
A WIDE THOUGH OF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING BUT THAT
THE FREQUENCY OF THESE BLOOMS.
OF HAS BEEN LASTING MUCH LONGER
AND AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
STATED THAT THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING THESE.
EH THROUGHOUT THE YEAR NOW
USUALLY THEY WERE IN THE SUMMER
I CAN TAILOR AUGUST TO
SEPTEMBER.
WE'VE HAD BLOOM IS HAPPENING
NOVEMBER DECEMBER AND JANUARY
AND SO RESERVOIRS THAT THAT
DOESN'T AFFECT SWIMMING AS MUCH
BUT THAT'S A AFFECT FISHING INTO
OUR RESERVOIRS AND ALSO SOME OF
THE THE BOATING ACTIVITIES.
SO I COULD YOUR SUPPORT AND.
THINK THIS IS A WELL GO GET
STEP TO BETTER COORDINATE OUR
EFFORTS AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS JUST MILAN
FOR THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS.
COMPLETELY CONCUR WITH THIS BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS THERE IS A
BIT OF OVERLAP BETWEEN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SOURCE THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
STATE WATER BOARD AND WE WOULD
URGE THAT TELL YOU INCLUDE LOCAL
AGENCIES IN THE CO ORDINATION.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH IS CALLED UPON TO
ACTUALLY POST TO CLOSE THESE
THESE LAKES WHEN IT'S OUTSIDE OF
THE JURISDICTION OF PARK SCHOOL
WOULD HAVE DISTRICTS SO WE URGE
AYE VOTE IN THIS BILL.
YOU NOT WISHING TO SPEAK CA.
FAVOR
THE MEASURE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TROUT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
TEAMED UP.
NO ONE ELSE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO MAKE.
MOTION.
AND A SECOND MY SO MEMBER RUBIO
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SUMMER MATHIS ARM QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR.
I I KNOW THIS YEAR NEVADA AS
WE'VE DEALT WITH THE YELLOW LAID
TREE FROG IN THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF RESEARCH THERE THAT PART OF
THE. THEM DYING OFF WAS BECAUSE
OF THE ALGAE BLOOMS IN THE HIVE
LAKES.
I JUST WANNA ASK WILL YEAR BE
THAT WITH THIS BILL WILL ALSO BE
LOOKING INTO THOSE AREAS AS
WELL.
IN CAN IN RESEARCH ON THOSE
ALGAE BLOOMS SO. WHAT HAS HAD?
THE YOM.
THE WATER BOARD CONVENED A.
A STUDY GROUP WITH A TOP PEOPLE.
AND THE IDEA THIS SPELL IS TO
TAKE WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
AND BRING IT FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTATION SO THIS IS A
REALLY TALKING ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION. I DO NOT KNOW
OUR DOES ANYONE KNOW IF THEY'VE
TAKEN A LOOK AT THE EFFECT ON
THE FROG.
YEAH SO THAT WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'VE LOOKED AT FROGS BUT WE
DO KNOW THAT THEY ARE LOOKING.
AT WAYS TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS
AND THEY SHOULD CERTAINLY HELP
OUT THE FROGS ARE BUT I'LL TRY
AND FIND OUT MORE AND GET BACK
TO YOUR OFFICE
OKAY I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IF IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
STATE'S BEEN MONEY ON DOING
RESEARCH ON THE ALGAE. THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL ASPECTS.
BECAUSE I HAD A LOT OF MY HIGH
SIERRA TRAILS CLOSE.
OVER YOU KNOW PEOPLE THINKING
THAT HUMANS WERE CAUSING THE
FROG DEATH WHEN I WAS ACTUALLY
THE ALGERIAN THOUGH. IF WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THE RESEARCH IS
GOING EVERYWHERE AND. YET WE
WILL DEFINITELY LOOK INTO THAT
AND.
.
THAT'S AGAIN IT THEY ARE LOOKING
AT MITIGATION THAT SHOULD HELP
IN ANY CASE BUT WILL LOOK
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE ARE HIGH.
THE HIGH LAKES IN THE SIERRAS.
THEY WILL ASK ABOUT THAT.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
I'M THIS IS. TRIGGERING
SOMETHING FOR ME.
WHEN I HAD AN INCIDENT WHERE.
.
DEALING WITH THERE'S LAKES AND
RESERVOIRS ARE MANAGED BY
ACTUALLY HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
UP IN MY OF THE IN MY DISTRICT.
WHERE THEY'RE TRYING TO TREAT
FOR ALGAL BLOOM AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY RAN INTO IS
THAT CERTAIN TREATMENTS THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO DO EVEN THOUGH?
MUNICIPALITIES ARE ALLOWED TO DO
THE TREATMENTS THAT ACTUALLY
PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS GROUPS ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO DO.
AND SOME OF THE TREATMENT SAID
THAT THEY HAD DONE JUST HAD TO
DEAL WITH IT.
.
THERE WAS AN EFFECT TO FISH FOR
FOR SOME REASON AND THEN THEY
ACTUALLY HAD FISH AND WILDLIFE
CAMINO AND SO I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN LIKE SOME KIND OF.
.
NO THAT ONE A TRY THE
COORDINATION I THINK IS
IMPORTANT ON THE SO ONE QUESTION
HOW DOES HAVE ENOUGH ANYBODY
KNOWS THIS BUT.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE TREATMENTS?
LETTER DONE THE KIND OF COMBAT
THE ALGAL BLOOM BLOOM AT THIS
POINT.
SO A MATT GROW GIVE CHIEF
STRICTLY THREE REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT UP SORTING A VARIETY OF
THINGS OF THERE'S TWO THINGS YOU
CAN DO ONE YOU CAN.
TREAT WITH THEM
HIS A BENIGN PRODUCT SOMEBODY
HYDROPEROXIDE WHEN YOU HAVE A
BLOOM LOVE THAT'LL THAT'LL
REDUCE THE LENGTH OF THE BLOOM
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
WHEN YOU. A TREAT WITH THE
HYDROPEROXIDE BASED PRODUCTS IT
BREAKS THE CELL WALLS AND
RELEASES THE TOXINS SO THEN YOU
CAN HAVE AN INCREASE PERIOD OF
TOXIN.
PRODUCTION EVEN THOUGH THE
ALBUM LOOK BETTER THEY TO LOOK
CLEAR ABOUT YOU MADE THE TOXINS
IN THE WATER SO WHAT WE FOUND TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
IN MANY OF OUR AS WE JUST
TREATING NUTRIENTS AHEAD OF TIME
BECAUSE NUTRIENTS ARE WHAT FEED
THE BLOOM SEE OF HIGH PHOSPHORUS
AND NITROGEN. IN THE RESERVOIRS
SO WE'VE BEEN PUTTING PRODUCTS.
IN INTO THE BOTTOM THE LAKE TO
FIND THOSE NUTRIENTS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO FEED THE ALGAE AND
THOSE TREATMENT OR MORE
EXPENSIVE IN THE MORE LONG TERM.
BUT I CAN SAY THAT THEY THAT
THAT WORK PICK WHAT COORDINATION
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD
WHETHER AND PANEL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT A TO GET THE PERMITS
TO DO THAT WORK WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO GET THOSE PERMITS BECAUSE
REPUBLIC AGENCY BUT I CAN
IMAGINE A HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
ANOTHER. TRYING TO WALK IN THE
FRONT DOOR AND COORDINATE WITH
THE WATER BOARD AND NOT HAVING
THAT SAME LEVEL OF.
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING HADDOCK A COMPLY
WITH THESE REGULATIONS
THAT ALREADY IN PLACE.
IT CAN BE VERY CHALLENGING SO I
THINK WE HAD THE COORDINATION IS
ESSENTIAL SOMETHING MAYBE THIS
IF FOR SOMEONE IF MOVE FOR MAYBE
TRYING TO INCLUDE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE SO DIFFERENT
PRIVATE GROUPS THAT MIGHT BE
INVOLVED WITH MANAGING.
RESERVOIRS AND LAKES RIGHT TED
THIS IS CLEARLY VERY IMPORTANT I
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT'LL FIT
INTO THIS BILL BUT IF IT DOES
THEN I PROMISE TO BRING
SOMETHING BACK NEXT YEAR. A TO
DEAL WITH.
LIKES ON PRIVATE PROPERTY OKAY
I JUST CAN'T SAY FOR SURE THAT
IT A COMPATIBLE WITH WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE. OF BUT IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT I PROMISE I WILL
GET TO.
IF NOT THIS YEAR THEN NEXT AND
AS I UNDERSTAND REALLY YOUR BILL
IS TRYING TO GET WATER BOARD.
TO COORDINATE WITH ALL THESE
GROUPS ON LIKE THAT SORT OF THE
A MORE UNIVERSAL WAVE.
COMBATING ALGAL BLOOM IS THAT IS
THAT RIGHT YEAH AND THE POINT
HERE IS THE REASON FOR THEIR
DOING IT WITH THE WATER BOARD IS
THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN.
THE.
INITIATIVE IN TERMS OF BRINGING
A GROUP TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE VARIOUS.
STRATEGIES ARE AND YOU JUST
HEARD FROM MR GROWL.
HOW?
SOME STRATEGIES CAN MAKE IT
WORSE IN OTHERS.
CAN BE PREVENTIVE
AND.
IDEALLY.
IF THE WATER BOARD COULD COME
UP WITH SOME STANDARD.
PERMIT.
THAT PEOPLE ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
COULD ASK FOR THAT'S WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE WHETHER I CAN DO IT
IN THIS BILL ARE NOT I DON'T
KNOW BUT AGAIN I PROMISE TO DO
IT EITHER THIS YEAR AND NEXT
OCCUR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
QUIRK.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
WOULD THAT. WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THOUGHT YES I HEARD.
THE.
SHARON FROM THE LOCAL AGENCIES
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE TALKING
WITH THEM. AND.
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
EVERYTHING IS COORDINATE WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH AGENCIES THANK
YOU I ASKED WE ARE AYE VOTE.
OKAY THAT MADAM CLERK WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BELOW I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
CHU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE HARPER.
KALRA. LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SOLACE. SOLACE I WOULD.
THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE CARILLO
.
SCRIPT THING.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PERCENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE A BILL
THAT TAKES COMMON SENSE STEPS TO
SAY WATER BY IMPROVING
LANDSCAPES DESIGN IRRIGATION
SYSTEMS. AND URBAN WATER USE
PRACTICES
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THAT COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANKING THEM FOR.
THE WORK WITHIN THAT'S BEING
DONE WITH MY STAFF TO.
THEN THE SPONSORS TO ENHANCE
THIS BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN LAYERED WITH SIGNED
INTO LAW AND DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES OR
D. WR.
TO CONVENE AN INDEPENDENT
TECHNICAL PANEL TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND RECOMMENDATIONS
WHO D. W. ARE. AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON WAYS TO MAKE
LANDSCAPE WATER USE MORE
SUSTAINABLE IN OUR STATE.
HOWEVER.
SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE PANEL
HAVE YET TO BE ACTED UPON NEARLY
TWO YEARS AFTER. THE PANEL
COMPLETED ITS WORK.
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WATER IS
USED OUTDOORS IN CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND TOWNS REDUCING WATER
USE ON URBAN LANDSCAPE
STATEWIDE.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE THE
EQUIVALENT OF ABOUT FOUR TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF WATER USED BY THE
ENTIRE. CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
ONE YEAR.
WATER EFFICIENT LANDSCAPE CAN
ALSO RESULT IN LESS AND LESS
INSTABILITY IN URBAN WATER
DEMAND AND IMPROVE. THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH AND SAVINGS
OVER WATER UTILITIES.
AND CA AND CUSTOMERS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
ADVANCE A SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
TECHNICAL PANEL'S REPORT THAT
HAVE POTENTIALLY THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE LANDSCAPE
WATER USE EFFICIENCY. AND OUR
STATE.
BY IMPROVING LANDSCAPE WATER
EFFICIENCY AND REDUCING WASTE WE
CONCEIVE ENERGY. LOWER WATER AND
A WASTE WATER TREATMENT COSTS
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR COSTLY
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND HELP CALIFORNIA MEET OUR
SHORT AND LONG TERM WATER
CHALLENGES.
MANY WHICH JONI IN THE LAKOTA
LANGUAGE MEANS WATER IS LIFE.
AND WATER IS AN ESSENTIAL SOURCE
IT'S AN ESSENTIAL RESOURCE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE AIMS
TO LOWER WATER AND WASTEWATER
TREATMENT COSTS AND HELP ENSURE
THE AFFORDABILITY.
OF THESE VITAL SERVICES IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I APPRECIATE THE INCREASE MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALBOA PARK.
AND I SHARE THE INTEREST IN
ENSURING THE BILL CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A MANNER THAT IS
INCLUSIVE. AND NOT HARMFUL TO
WORKERS OR CONSUMERS
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
IN THE CONSIDERATIONS MENTIONED
IN THE ANALYSIS. REGARDING HOME
INSPECTIONS AND I WILL INPUT AND
WELCOME THE INPUT OF THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY.
OUR GLENFERRIE ALL OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY AND
AT AUSTIN FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
THANK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
STEPPING IN FOR GLENN LAST
MINUTE HERE I'M MY NAME IS JEFF
STEVENSON AND I'M WITH THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY. I
ALSO SERVED AS ONE OF THE SEVEN.
STATE WHITE PANEL MEMBERS ON
THE INDEPENDENT TECHNICAL PANEL
THAT DEVELOPED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
LANDSCAPE WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
MISTER CHAIR I KNOW THAT YOU
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF YOUR COMMITTEE
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN RUBIO GLORIA. GALLAGHER
AND BIGELOW HAVE PLAYED
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN HELPING
CALIFORNIA SHAPE ITS LONG TERM
WATER CHRISTIANS POLICY.
WHETHER THAT PACKAGE OF BILLS
COMES TOGETHER IN THE COMING
DAYS WEEKS OR MONTHS.
IT'S FAIRLY CLEAR THAT THE FINAL
STATUTORY PACKAGE WILL LIKELY
INCLUDE OUTDOOR WATER USE
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS.
WELL AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
DOESN'T CONTAIN PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD STAND ALONE AS LANDMARK
WATER CONSERVATION MEASURES.
COLLECTIVELY THE PROVISIONS OF
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE ARE
IMPORTANT IN HELPING WATER
MANAGERS IN WATER CONSUMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE MOVE
FORWARD AND MEETING ANY NEW
OUTDOOR WATER USE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE
THE SORT OF COMMONSENSE TOOLS
THAT CAN HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S
LANDSCAPE IRRIGATION EFFICIENCY.
AND WATER CONSERVATION ETHIC.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE AND ENCOURAGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE MEASURE
THIS MORING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS IT.
SAN AMONG THE WATER PROGRAM OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
I'M ALSO SERVED ON THE IDW ARE
INDEPENDENT TECHNICAL PANEL ON
URBAN WATER EFFICIENCY FOR ABOUT
THREE YEARS AND WE'RE DELIGHTED
TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL ALONG
WITH HIS SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY.
THE BILL YOU HAVE A BEFORE YOU.
HAS ABOUT FIVE OR SIX VERY
DISCRETE COMPONENTS TO IT.
EACH ELEMENT OF THE BILL IS
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FROM FROM THE
OTHERS AND I THINK THAT REFLECTS
THE FACT THAT.
PANEL STUDIED THIS ISSUE THE
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WATER THAT
USED OUTDOORS. ENOUGH.
IN CALIFORNIA THAT A WEEK
ADDRESSED A NUMBER OF WAYS TO
TRY TO.
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE EXCESSIVE
WATER USE OUTDOORS NUMBER
STRATEGIES A NUMBER OF TOOLS.
COMING AT IT FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS SO THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S THE PRODUCT THAT'S
HOW THIS. THIS.
RATHER DIVERSE SET OF
RECOMMENDATINS GOT ASSEMBLED
AND GOT IN FRONT OF YOU HERE
TODAY.
WE'RE JUST SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
WITH THE.
I BELIEVE THERE FIVE COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
RECOMMENDED.
OTHER TESTIMONY OR PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT THEM ON AND ON.
A MARINE ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SEEN NO OTHER A
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
HI MY NAME IS DAVE PACE I M. OF
THE LEGISLATIVE.
CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION.
AND IMMEDIATE PAST CHAIRMAN OF
THE BOARD OF THAT ASSOCIATION.
A WE ARE NOT WE HAVE NOT
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BUT WE WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND.
GO OVER SOME CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE TO CLEAR A SECTION TO THE
BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER BROWN.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NURSERIES AND GARDEN CENTERS.
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
WERE NOT IN OPPOSITION TO THE
GOALS THE BILL.
AND THE NURSERY GARDEN CENTER IN
INDUSTRY THE STATE CALIFORNIA I
THINK HAS PLAYED A. VERY STRONG
ROLE. OVER THE YEARS IN DOING
OUR PART TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS.
AND PROVIDE KNOWLEDGE WHERE WE
CAN SPECIALLY AT THE RETAIL
CENTER OUT FOR CONSUMERS AS THEY
MAKE. THEIR PURCHASING OF
OUTDOOR LANDSCAPE.
WE'VE ALSO WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH IRRIGATION INDUSTRY A
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS AND OTHERS
BECAUSE REALLY. THEN THE MAIN
SOURCE OF LANDSCAPE WASTE OUR
OUR IRRIGATION SYSTEM.
AND NOT WITHSTAND THE FACT THAT
WE'VE START TO INCORPORATE WE DO
INCORPORATE MUCH MORE TRIPS
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT MEANS NOTHING IF
THE CONSUMER AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE HOMEOWNER AT THE END OF
THE DAY THE PROPERTY OWNER
CANDIDATE DOESN'T IT JUST THAT
IRRIGATION SYSTEM ACCORDINGLY
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IS THAT COME WITH THE
WEATHER AND THE CLIMATIC
DIFFERENCES.
OUR CONCERN WITH THIS IS IS
REALLY TWO FOLD AND IT'S NOT
JUST ONE SPECIFIC AREA THE BILL
THAT DEALS WITH THE LABELING OF
PLANTS.
FIRST.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'LL PROVIDE
THE EDUCATION OR THE KNOWLEDGE
THE CONSUMER.
THAT THE BILL PROFESSOR SO IT
WILL FOR EXAMPLE.
IT'LL BE A NURSERY AYE IN TULARE
COUNTY OR KINGS COUNTY OR MADERA
COUNTY THAT'S ACTUALLY PRODUCING
THIS THESE PLANTS THAT WILL MOVE
ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HERE NOW REQUIRING THAT NURSERY
OWNER TO ACCOMMODATE AND PLAN
FOR WHERE THOSE PLANTS WILL
ULTIMATELY END UP TO PROVIDE A
LABEL THAT WILL BE SPECIFIC TO
THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THE
CLIMATIC AREA. FOR THAT PLANT
THE IT SAYS IT IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT I'M A PLANT LIKE AN AZALEA.
MAY BE CONSIDERED A HIGH WATER
PLANT.
BUT THAT COULD CHANGE DEPENDING
ON THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA WHERE
IT'S PLANTED.
AND CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE DO HAVE A
FLOURISHING NURSERY INDUSTRY.
ARE ALL THE DIFFERENT CLIMATIC
pAREAS THE GEOGRAPHICAL ZONES
THE
ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
TO PLANT A LARGE VARIETY OF
PLANTS.
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
AND DEPENDING ON WHERE THAT
PLANT IS GROWN. ITS WATER USE
WILL CHANGE
SO. PLANTS ARE SOPHISTICATED
BEANS AND THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT GOES INTO THE CARE AND
NURTURE OF A PLANT THAN SIMPLY A
LABEL. AND WORK SO WERE AFRAID
THAT JUST BY PUTTING A LABEL ON
A PLANT WILL NOT GIVE
THE TYPE A NOTICE THAT A
CONSUMER WOULD REALLY NEED TO
MAKE THOSE BUYING DECISIONS.
SECONDLY IT'S GONNA ADD
INCREASED LABOR.
TO THE NURSERY INDUSTRY WHICH
IS ALREADY STRUGGLING OF WITH.
YOU NOTE THAT THE ECONOMY IS IS
COMING BACK HAS BEEN SLOW ON THE
SIDE OF THE ON THE NURSERY AND
NOW WE'RE GONNA BE ADDING LABELS
ICE LIKE I SAID EARLIER THOSE
LABELS NEED TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
WHERE THEY'RE GOING. AND WE JUST
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE
SO.
WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO HELP CONSERVE WATER IN THE
STATE F CALIFORNIA WE JUST
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IDEA OF
PUTTING A. LABEL ON A PLANT WILL
HELP US GET THERE AND THEREFORE
WE OPPOSED THE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHERS CURRENTLY NOT
EMOTION IF ANY WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ONE.
BOOK.
IT'S MADE BY MISTER CHIU.
SECOND I MISS FRIEDMAN.
I MISTER MATHIS.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
PROJECTED COSTS IS GONNA BE?
FIT TO RUN ALL THIS NEW PROGRAM
AND AND ALL THIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A COST ESTIMATE.
I REALLY DO NOT I DON'T HAVE
THAT IN FRONT OF ME BUT HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF IN YOURSELF
TO FIGURE THIS AGO CESAR HONOR
THE.
MY MY LARGEST CONCERN HERE IS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH
WATER AND STATE. OF SEVERAL
MEASURES GOING THROUGH. ON QUITE
FRANKLY IN A IN YOU DON'T KNOW
THE COSTA BEYOND BILL.
WHICH IS DISTURBING IN ITSELF.
.
WHY ARE WE LOOKING TO DO MORE
PURPLE FIVE USE MORE RECYCLED
WATER FROM THE FUNDING THEIR?
THAT THERE'S A HUNDRED ONE
OTHER OPTIONS OTHER THAN
CREATING A BURDEN ON OTHER
INDUSTRIES.
IN MORE GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS A
PROBLEM THAT WE ALL KNOW IS.
BEING ADDRESSED IN OTHER WAYS SO
I MEAN YOU'RE NOT GONNA MY
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE I
ENCOURAGE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT. YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH A FUNDING.
FOR THINGS WE WE'VE GOT TO DO
MORE TO TO CONSERVATIVE BE SMART
WITH WATER BUT CREATING IN
SPENDING MONEY ON PROGRAMS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WHERE THERE ARE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW ARE TRACKING?
WE WE'VE GOT A CONSERVE ALL OUR
RESOURCES.
NOT SURE IF YOU WERE SITTING
DOWN AND I DIDN'T REALIZE
WHETHER YOU'RE HERE WHEN I WAS
SPEAKING BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY A
CONTINUATION OF AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL THAT
PASSED TWO YEARS AGO. IT'S
ACTUALLY MAKING THOSE
IMPLEMENTATIONS A REALITY YES
AND I I WAS HERE THE SORRY I DID
DURING THAT TIME I DIDN'T SEE IN
HERE THE ENTIRE TIME SO THIS IS
ALSO. AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT DON'T OFTEN WORK TOGETHER.
THAT HAVE COME TO THE TABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY.
INCLUDING A COALITION OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS.
IN ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE A STATE.
THAT ACTUALLY PUTS THE LAWS THAT
THEY PLAN IN PLACE.
AND THAT WE ARE CONSERVING WATER
IN THE BEST WAYS THAT WE CAN SO
PEOPLE CHECK OUT OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE OF THE IN THE NEW
ISSUE ON DISTRICT.
I I WELCOME WORKING WITH YOU IN
FIGURING THAT OUT SIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI.
NOW MY QUESTION NOW IS THAT THE
I HEAR THE REQUIREMENT IS SO
LARGELY PLACED ON THE NURSERY
ASIDE AND THEN.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING I THINK
IN THEIR SERIES.
GENERALLY TONES START THE
COMMITTEE AT THE RETAILER CELL
AND THE FARMER SO REGIONALLY
TAKE ROLL AND THE SOUTH
NURSERIES.
A I WONDER IF ARE THE ORIGIN ON
A CULTIVATOR SO.
OF FROM THE SEED THAT THEY CUT
TO PAY THE UNPAID THOUGH MORE
EXPORTS OF FOR THEM TO ORIGINATE
TARA. THE LABEL ACCOUNTABLE
WATER MAY BE. NECESSARY BECAUSE
OF RECENTLY I BOUGHT A PLAN
DAYS.
IN OUR OUR SELDOM CAN FOR A
PLANT THE BELOW MY WATER.
MY HOPE FOUNTAIN AND GO. WHERE
THEY MAY BE LACK OF US SON?
SO OF US ARE LOOKING FOR.
W. CLIMATE THE SUN Y. SHAPE THE
WHERE THE PLANT CAN PATROL.
AND THAT THEY OR NAY BUT THE BY
THE COLLAR AND A NIGHT IT WAS
ABLE TO CHOOSE THAT THE PROP ONE
UNTIL. AFTER TWO THREE MONTHS IS
STILL SURVIVING SO.
I'M I MUST ABOUT THE HERE RIGHT
TIED INTO.
SO AS SUCH THAT THE ORIGINAL.
IDEA COME FROM THE GERMINATION
OF THE SEED COAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD KNOW BETTER.
THE RATHER THAN PUTTING THAT
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO THE BRIDGE
RETAILER ESSA.
AND THEY MAY NOT KNOW YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE TO DO WITH THEIR OWN
RESEARCH.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT THE
HOW YOU CAN SOLVE THE KIND OF
PROBLEM.
YES IF I MIGHT MISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
.
THE THE BILL.
THE LABELING REQUIREMENTS IN
THE BILL.
BUT LARGELY SUPPLEMENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
CURRENT LAW IN FACT MUCH THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RELATING
TO.
TO LABELING ESERVER STATE IS A
RESTATEMENT OF CURRENT LAW.
BUT LABELS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
ON ON LANDSCAPE PLANTS IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE PRIMARY.
AFFECT OF THIS BILL IS TO ADD
THE WATER USE CLASSIFICATION.
FOR THAT PLANT.
TWO THE LABELING REQUIREMENT
THAT IS ALREADY THERE.
THAT'S PRIMARILY.
THE AFFECTED THE BILL SO THOSE
WHO ARE LABELING NOW WOULD
CONTINUE TO LABEL WITH WITH.
ADDING THE WATER USE DESIGNATION
FOR THAT PLAN.
ADMITTEDLY THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
SOME SOME.
NUANCES ABOUT HOW A LABELING
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE FASHION.
THE BILL CALLS FOR FOOD NAG TO
DO THIS THROUGH A RULE MAKING BY
TWENTY TWENTY SO THERE IS TIME.
WE WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WOULD
BE A STAKEHOLDER.
FRAMEWORK THAT FOOD NAG WOULD
SET UP TO TO TAKE GUIDANCE FROM.
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS ON HOW
THE THE LABELING PROGRAM SHOULD
BE SET UP.
AND THAT AND I THINK YOU A
TEACHER I WOULD HAVE MORE YEAH
ADDITIONAL QUESTION HIM.
IF I MAY ARE IS THAT.
UNLESS OUT THAT IS SO SPECIFIC
IN THE WAR PLANT.
AND THE THE CONSUMER MAY PAY.
A ATTENTION.
AND THEN I I TEND TO OVER WATER
AND A MY WIFE BUT TRUST ME TONE
WATER UTILITY IN OFFICE SO SO
IT'S AUTHORED THE COMMONSENSE SO
WE WE LEARN AND A.
BUT THE IF.
A PLANTS I BY FOR OUTDOORS.
AND OF THAT OR DIFFERENT KINDS.
AND THE USUALLY WE WATER BASED
UPON THE SEASON SOMETIME.
IN A MORE FREQUENT THAT
WINTERTIME MAYBE ONCE OR TWICE A
WEEK IN IN GENERAL.
SO STE REQUIRING SPECIFIC
WATERMARK THE FULL OR DIFFERENT
PLANS SO ON THE COTTON HOW THAT
WOULD REALLY HELP OTHER THAN.
IN ALL LABOR COSTA AND THEN IF
EVENTUALLY THE CONSUMERS WILL
END UP PAYING MORE.
NO SEWER I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THIS WOULD BE REALLY.
BENEFICIAL AND.
SUBSTANTIALLY SAVED THE WATER
SO.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE.
DID THE MANDATED.
ACOSTA FOR THE NURSERIES TO TO
PROVIDE THAT KIND WHEN LABELS
THAT'S MY CONCERN.
IF I MAY I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
PART OF IT IS ALSO EDUCATE EIGHT
EDUCATING THE CONSUMER SO IF
YOU'RE GONNA BUY.
.
ROSES.
THEY REQUIRE A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
WATER USE
THEN A CACTUS.
AND YOU WOULDN'T NORMALLY PUT
THOSE TWO TOGETHER.
SO FOR YOUR OWN PERSONAL GARDEN
IT'S ALSO ABOUT WHAT YOU WANT
AND HOW YOU PLACE IT AND SO IF
YOU ARE BUYING PLANTS THAT
ALREADY TELL YOU WHAT THE WATER
USES.
THEN YOU'RE GONNA DIVIDE YOUR
GARDEN BASED ON THAT WATER USE.
AND YOUR NOT GONNA BE PUTTING.
HOPEFULLY YOU WON'T BE PUTTING.
FLOWERS NEXT TO OTHER TYPES OF
PLANTS THAT ARE REQUIRED THE
SAME WATER USE.
AND THAT WAY YOU'RE ALSO SAVING
WATERING YOUR WATER BILL. IN
YOUR GARDEN CAN REFLECT
A DIVERSITY OF.
OF NATURE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA THANK
YOU SIR.
MYSTERY THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION I WAS.
I'VE NAY APPRECIATE INVOLVEMENT
IN THE SUPPORT OF UP OF THIS MY
LOCAL AGENCIES FROM SAN DIEGO I
WANT TO ASK YOU TO MAYBE RESPOND
IN KIND OF THIS A LITTLE BIT
ALREADY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS BUT TO WHAT MISTER
BROWN WAS TALKING ABOUT. SEEM
LIKE THERE'S SOME PRACTICAL
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THAT'S.
WOULD PLAY OUT I'M I RECKON
IT'S FAIRLY EARLY IN THE PROCESS
OF BUT I AYE YEAH FINE MISTER
BROWN BEASLEY PAID VERY
THOUGHTFUL VERY PRAGMATIC. YOU
TALK A LITTLE THAT WHAT HE
RAISED IN WHAT HOW YOU MIGHT
RESPOND TO THOSE CONCERNS.
WELL I'M HAPPY TO.
TO CONTINUE LOOKING AT THIS
BILL AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO BEST MOVE IT FORWARD AND ALSO
WORK WITH OUR SPONSORS IN TERMS
OF.
RAISING SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
AND FIGURING IT OUT.
AND I WAS ONE A PLAN FOR THE
RECORD I I BELIEVE I SHARE MR
MET HER MATHIS IS CONCERNS
ABOUT.
THE LACK OF FISCAL.
RECOGNITION ON IT ARE ON THIS
ITEM BUT IT'S TRUE OF EVERY ITEM
THE AYE FOR WHITE MEN UNDERSTAND
THIS PLACE WHERE ALL THE FISCAL
IMPACTS ALWAYS IS UNKNOWN. I
REALIZE AGAIN IT'S IN THE BEING
THE PROCESS BUT I WOULD HOLD YOU
PERSONALLY COUNSEL FOR THAT
BECAUSE WITHOUT EITHER A BILLS
TODAY THAT ALREADY HAVE THE SAME
BUSINESS DOZEN NATIONS YOURS.
THANK YOU.
YEAH I MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YEAH I'D WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I JUST WANT TO GIVE A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT PERSONAL TO ME. MY
HUSBAND IS A LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTOR TO PROFESSIONAL
LANDSCAPE DESIGNER. AND KNOWING
ABOUT.
THE THINGS I'D THIS BILL WOULD
CODIFY ABOUT LANDSCAPE
CONSERVATION ABOUT TO I'M THE
TYPE DIFFERENT TYPES OF WATER
EFFICIENT IRRIGATION SYSTEMS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR HIS
BUSINESS. AND I KNOW THAT NOT
EVERY LANDSCAPE CONTRACTOR
ALWAYS HAS BEEN EDUCATED.
OUR ARE IN IN THAT AREA I KNOW
THAT BECAUSE HE MAKES A LOT OF
MONEY GOING IN FIXING OTHER
PEOPLE'S MISTAKES.
AND THE PERSON WHO ENDS UP
REALLY BEARING THE BRUNT OF THAT
ARE THE CONSUMERS.
AND THE SAME WAY THAT CONSUMERS
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE FINANCIAL
COST WHEN THEY GO TO A
LANDSCAPE.
THEY GO TO A NURSERY AND THEY
UNKNOWINGLY BY SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY WATER THIRSTY AND THE PLANT
DIES YOUR LEADER. SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL SAVE
CONSUMERS MONEY.
IT BY MAKING SURE THAT THE
CONTRACTORS WHO WORK ON THEIR
LANDSCAPES HAVE THE PROPER
EDUCATION.
FOR WHAT WE NEED.
TO KEEP OUR LANDSCAPESHEALTHY
WOULD EMIT DROUGHT CONDITIONS
AND ALSO FOR HOMEOWNERS TO KNOW.
WHAT THE CONDITIONS ARE OF THE
PLANTS THEIR PURCHASING AND HOW
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM?
IT'S NOT DIFFICULT FOR
NURSERIES TO PUT THIS
INFORMATION ON LABELS SOME OF
THEM DO IT TO GO TO HOME DEPOT
FOR IT LIKE SHOULDN'T MENTION
ANY PARTICULAR NURSERY. BUT
THEY'LL PUT PLANTS IN THE AREAS
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF WATER USE
BUT A LOT OF NURSERIES DON'T DO
THAT. SO THIS IS A VERY THESE
ARE VERY COMMON SENSE MEASURES
THAT HAVE BEEN ENACTED RECENTLY
BUT REALLY SHOULD BE ENSHRINED
IN LAW AND I THINK THAT THEY'RE
VERY CONSUMER FRIENDLY SO. I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR ONCE
AGAIN.
THANKS WAS FRIEDMAN MISTER CHIU.
UNSINKABLE MAJORITY SUPPORTED
THIS BILL BECAUSE I. DO I DON'T
SEE DOORS NO.
.
ONE SOLUTION THAT WOULD REALLY
IMPROVE TO YOUR.
DATE THEIR WATER.
CONSERVATION PURPOSE TOLD
DISPEL WITCHES AND ANOTHER TOOL
THAT WE CAN USE.
I EVER HEARD A COMPLAINT I MEAN
TO YOU THAT THE TESTIMONY FROM
THE NURSERY.
AND I FELT OF. THE ALTERNATIVE
IS PROBABLY EVEN WORSE TO DAD
NURSE BUT TO TO ADAPT BIRD
SECTOR. OF DIVERSAS FOAM
CALIFORNIA RUN OUT OF WATER.
SO ARE WE ARE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RUBIO.
THANK YOU WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
I'M A DID REACH OUT SEVERAL
TIMES AND ARE THE AUTHORS OFFICE
WAS VERY RESPONSIVE TO. TO THE
THE QUESTIONS AND SO I DO AGREE
WITHOUT MISTER GLORIA ABOUT
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE ISSUE
FOR THE NURSERIES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU.
DATA THE AUTHORS OFFICE WAS
VERY RESPONSIVE SO I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUES TO SPEAKING TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT THE
ISSUE AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME
TO A RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
SEEN NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE THE MEMBERS
MISS CARILLO CHUCK CLOSE.
THANK YOU A YES I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO ALSO
LOOK AT THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
SPELL ON THE FACT SHEET.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
ISSUES AND TO.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
BURBANK RAISES A REALLY.
IMPORTANT POINT IS THAT SOME
NURSERIES ALREADY DO THE
LABELING. AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR CONSUMERS TO UNDERSTAND THE
TYPE OF PLANTS AND FLOWERS THAT
THEY'RE BUYING SO THAT THEY. AT
THE END OF THE DAY SAVE MONEY
AND SAFE WATER THAT IS REALLY
THE INTENT OF OVER TRYING TO DO
HERE. AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO AS YOU
NOTED IN YOUR OPENING YOU
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE OF THE
MET AMENDMENTS AND THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE CHAIRS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
STICK AROUND BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
A SECOND BILL AFTER THIS.
CALL THE.
THE ROLE.
XIN IS.
THE MOTION IS TO.
AMENDED TO THE.
ABILITY AND.
VIEW.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
CARILLO.
I CARILLO AYE CHOI NAY. CHOI NO.
CHIU ARE.
CHIU HIGH.
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA.
LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO. RUBIO.
RUBIO I SAW LESS.
WOULD.
THE VOTE IS SIX FOR IT WILL
REMAIN ON CALL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE AYE AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN NOW
MISS KOREA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AGAIN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN A BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES FOR
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH AND IMPROVE
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE LITTLE TO NO
ACCESS TO OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
THIS IS ESPECIALLY PERVASIVE. IN
URBAN AREAS AMONG COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHERE CHILDREN HAVE
LIMITED MEANS TO TRAVEL TO AND
FROM OUTDOOR SPACES.
IN MY FIFTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WE HAVE CHILDREN WHO
LIVE MERELY FIFTEEN MILES AWAY
FROM THE BEACH YET HAVE NEVER
SEEN IT OR EXPERIENCE THAT. NO
ONE SHOULD BE DENIED SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
IS SO CLOSE BY.
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS IN
GENERAL HAS NUMEROUS BENEFITS
FOR YOU THAT HELPS THEM GET
MOVING AND ACTIVE. IN THE
OUTDOORS AND PROMOTES HEALTH AND
MOUNT MENTAL WELLNESS
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THE OUTDOORS CAN ENCOURAGE A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. INCLUDING
NATURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
CURRENTLY MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE SCHOOL BUSES THAT GO UNUSED
ON THE WEEKEND. IN SOME CASES
THESE BUSES CAN BE CONTRACTED TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE
THEM TO PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION.
HOWEVER MANY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND STATE AGENCIES
ARE UNAWARE.
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF SCHOOL
BUSES TO TRANSPORT TO HELP OUR
YOUTH GET TO OUR STATE PARKS AND
OUTDOOR SPACES.
FURTHERMORE NUMEROUS WORTHY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS OUR STATE AGENCIES LACK THE
FUNDING AND MEANS NECESSARY TO
SERVE OUR UNDERPRIVILEGED YOUTH.
AMONG MANY OTHERS PARTICULARLY
WHERE TRANSPORTATION IS
CONCERNED.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN WILL TASK
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
WITH COMPILING A LIST OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT CONTRACT.
OUT THEIR SCHOOL BUSES TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
STATE AGENCIES FOR
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
THE AGENCY WILL THEN MAKE THOSE
LIST AVAILABLE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND STATE AGENCIES
A PROVIDER DISADVANTAGED YOUTH
WITH OUTDOOR.
EXPERIENCES
THIS WOULD CONNECT ORGANIZATIONS
WITH TRANSPORTATION SERVICES TO
GIVE OUR TO SERVING YOU POSITIVE
ENCOUNTERS WITH NATURE.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN ALSO
CREATES A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDS TO FOSTER
MORE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS. AND
ENCOURAGE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
OFFER THESE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES TO DO SO USING LOW
EMISSION BUSES.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS JOSE
ONE SILENCE THE FOUNDER OF
LATINO OUTDOORS AND HOLLY
MARTINEZ OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HOLLY MARTINEZ
DIRECTOR PROGRAMS AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE. PARKS
FOUNDATION I'M HERE TO SPUR AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CREATORS LEADERSHIP IN
INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH. IT'S
UNDENIABLE THE OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES PROVIDED NUMBER OF
POSITIVE OUTCOMES AND BENEFITS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION WE BELIEVE PARK
EXPERIENCES ARE SUCH FOR HEALTH
HAPPINESS AND QUALITY OF LIFE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SOME OF
THE MOST UNIQUE AND WORLD FAMOUS
NATURAL RESOURCES AND STATE AND
NATIONAL PARKS THAT DRAW
THOUSANDS OF TOURISTS ANNUALLY.
IT THE REALITY IS THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCES TREASURES THAT
RESIDE IN THEIR OWN BACKYARD.
FOR MANY FAMILIES PARTICULAR
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF MODEST
ECONOMIC MEANS LACK OF RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE AT
PARKS AND OPEN SPACES. ARE
OVERWHELMING BARRIERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT EVERYBODY
REGARDLESS OF SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS LANGUAGE ABILITY GENDER
RACE CULTURE ZIP CODE. SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
THE BEAUTY. AND BENEFITS OF
PARKS
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO EXPLORE ONE OF THE
MANY PATHWAYS.
A PARKS THAT BEING
TRANSPORTATION AVAILABILITY
THROUGH SCHOOL DISTRICT BUS
SUITES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS
NONPROFITS AND OTHER AGENCIES
ARE ACCESSING TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS.
AND THE NOW TELLING CALIFORNIANS
OF MOBILE TO MOBILE GENERATIONS
NOT JUST YOUTH TO THE OUTDOORS
ON A REGULAR BASIS.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN PROPOSAL
FOR SURVEYING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO UNDERSTAND THE BUS FLEETS.
AND ESTABLISHING A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS IS A
POSITIVE STEP TOWARD HELPING
MANY PARK PARTNERS WE WORK WITH.
NOT TO MENTION ALL THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ALREADY
DOING THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
A POTENTIALLY EXPAND THEIR
OUTDOOR PROGRAMMING TO SERVE
MORE CALIFORNIANS.
WE HAVE HAD A VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE ABOUT ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THEM ON THIS POTENTIAL PATHWAY
TO GET MORE CALIFORNIANS
OUTDOORS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
HELLO. MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME BECAUSE THEY
WANT SILENCE I'M HERE WITH THAT
THE NOT DOORS.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN.
FOR A COUPLE OF THINGS WILL
FIRST OF ALL THAT THE NOT DOORS
IS A PRETTY UNIQUE.
AT THE NEXT LED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO DO WORK OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
IF THE SOME OF THE AREAS AND
REGIONS IN WHICH THAT DIVERSITY
OF LATINO COMMUNITIES.
FOR WHICH I'M GONNA START
THERE'S AT LEAST KIND OF THREE
GIVEN THAT I SEE AND THAT KIND
OF THREE OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES INTO THIS BILL.
PART OF THE GIVEN SAYS THAT.
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF CALIFORNIA
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO CHANGE
AND WE NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK SO
TO SPEAK IN TERMS OF
CONSERVATION STEWARDSHIP OF OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES.
OUGHT TO IS THAT I THINK THE
RESEARCH IS THERE TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THAT POSITIVE TRANSFORMATIVE
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES ARE KEY.
OTHER ESSENTIAL FOR ALL CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD ARGUE FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
IN CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
BEST PERIOD I MEAN TERMS OF
STATE PARKS AND OTHER PUBLIC
LANDS AND EVERYTHING FROM CITY
ALL THE WAY TO FEDERAL PUBLIC
LANDS WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE THREE POINTS IS THAT.
ONE OF THEM IS THIS QUESTION OF
EQUITY AND INIQUITY GAPPING GOT
AN AN AXIS.
IT'S NOT NEW.
BUT WE REALLY NEEDS REPORTS TO
GET TRANSPORTATION CONTINUES TO
BE ONE OF THE MOST.
EASY TO IDENTIFY SOMETIMES HARD
TO TACKLE A BARRIERS IN TERMS
VOWED TO ACCESS.
SCHOOL DISTRICT TEND TO BE ONE
OF THE BEST ASSETS AT A
COMMUNITY HAS ANOTHER AN ANCHOR
THEIR WELL KNOWN.
HA.
THE SECOND PIECE IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY CAN
SERVICE THAT CONNECTION IN THE
ABILITY TO GET MORE KIDS
OUTDOORS NOT JUST HIM SOME MORE.
KIDS SCHOOL CHILDREN BUT THE
KIDS ARE SERVED BY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
NONPROFITS THAT USUALLY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES ARE LIMITED
LOGISTICALLY IT
THE CHALLENGES OF
TRANSPORTATION.
THE SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE TO THE
FINAL PIECES KNOWING THAT. TO BE
ABLE TO TACKLE THE
TRANSPORTATION PIECE WITH THE
FUNDING QUESTION CAN BE PRETTY
TRANSFORMATIVE AND REVOLUTIONARY
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CONTINUES TO
BE A PROBLEM. SO WE SEE THAT YOU
KNOW THIS BILL.
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COMMITTEE ON PUT ON THE ON
BEHALF OF ONGOING CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER THE NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
SIN CREDIBLE IMPORTANT BILL IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
SILENCE ALICE POTTER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAHOE ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA OR BEEN FORCED
COUNCIL AND THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION AND CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ELLEN OR TEASE ON BEHALF OF
BIG SIR LEON TRUSS MOHAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST AND SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THINK YOU.
HELLO QUAN CARMONA ON BEHALF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MARK FENCE TO MAKE THEM
HAPPY ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THE WILDLINGS CONSERVANCY AND
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SHAUN DRAKE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
THE COMMISSION IS NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY YET TO TAKE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL HOWEVER IT
WILL BE DOING SO LATER THIS WEEK
AND STAFF WILL STRONGLY
RECOMMEND A SUPPORT POSITION.
A MARINE ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
REPORTING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STUCK HOUSTON REPRESENT
A CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERS CALIFORNIA PARK AND
RECREATION SOCIETY AND THEN
FINALLY THE OUTDOOR INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WHERE ON SUPPORT.
IT ANY ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SCENE AND I BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
.
MR BICU.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A.
QUESTION UNDER SECTION ONE CODE
FIVE SIX
TWO OF THE BILL WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF OF LOW EMISSION
BUSES.
WELL I DON'T HAVE THE DEFINITION
IN FRONT OF ME BUT HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF TO MAKE SURE YOU
GET THAT I THINK ARE OUR MAIN
CONCERN PERFORMING GOAL IS THAT
SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT'S
WE MENTIONED EARLIER. ALREADY
USE LOW EMISSION BUT.
SO IF WE ARE TRYING TO GET YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GO TO THE OUTDOORS TO
CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REAL. OUR FIRST OPTION IS TO TRY
TO USE THE LOW EMISSION BUSES
OUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S
NOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE CASE
BUT IT SHOULD BE THE FIRST
PRIORITY.
RIGHT AND.
BUTTON THOUGH EVERYTHING THAT I
WAS ASKING IS.
UP I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT AND EVENTUALLY WITH YOUR
OFFICE ABOUT INCLUDING.
PROPANE BY SAYS AS PART OF THE
LOW EMISSIONS ACCORDING TO THE
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD PROPANE
IS A CLEAN COST EFFECTIVE A
MEASURE SOLD THAT'S WHY I WAS
ASKING SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
INCLUDE THAT AS PART OF. OF THE
THE LIST OF WHAT I LOW EMISSION
BUSES.
I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT.
MR BAYLOR.
THANK YOU MAYBE FOR THE AUTHOR.
MAYBE YOU COULD HELP IDENTIFY
WHERE THE FUNDING COMES.
FOR MEETING THE SHORT GAP AS
YOU KNOW OUR STATE PARKS ARE.
REALLY IN A DESPERATE.
POSITION OF HAVING.
NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
NOT GIVING THE FULL WRATH OF THE
EXPERIENCE INTO OUR STATE PARKS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE ALL THE USER
TO HAVE ESPECIALLY THE
DISADVANTAGE WHO CAN'T MAYBE
MAKE ACCESS. TO A LOT OF THOSE
AREAS BECAUSE ARE NOW CUT OFF.
ARM.
I'M WANTING IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN
TO US HOW WE'RE GONNA MAKE UP
THE SHORTFALL WHERE THE FUNDING
WILL COME. FOR THE PROPOSED.
IDEA SURE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ASSESSING COSTS AS WELL.
AND I THINK FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE FOR LOOKING AT
POLICY THAT'S GOOD FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND GOOD FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AXES. AND ONCE IT
GETS TO A A BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THAT WE COULD BEGIN TO ADDRESS
MORE OF THE SERIOUS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPLEMENTATION
BUT WE SHARE YOUR CONCERNS. AND
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ACCENTS
TO TRANSPORTATION.
FOR ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS OUR
STATE THEY WANNA GIVE ACCESS TO
YOUNG PEOPLE IT CAN TAKE. IT
COST SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
RENT A BUS.
TO TAKE KIDS FIFTEEN MILES.
AND SO A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS
DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF FUNDING
AND SO I HAVE ANOTHER.
.
BILL IN CONCURRENT TO THIS THAT
HELPS TO ADDRESS THAT THIS IS
ONE PARTICULAR ASPECT THAT WOULD
HELP.
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
THE LISTS.
OF THE SCHOOLS THAT ALSO.
PROVIDE THE BUSES FOR
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT THERE
COULD BE BETTER A TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCESS.
SO COULD WE EXPECT. FROM YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
YOUR REQUEST WON'T HAMPER THE
STATE PARKS OR THE PARKS THAT
WILL BE AFFECTED BY THIS FROM.
THEIR CURRENT LEVEL OF FUNDING
SO THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT THE GOOD WORK THAT THEY DO
DEL AND THAT THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
ELEMENTS WHICH ALWAYS GET
PUSHED OFF TO THE BACK BURNER
BECAUSE THERE'S NEW REQUIREMENTS
PUT PLACED ON.
CAN WE MAKE CAN WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT FROM YOU THAT YOU
WON'T BE A ATTACHING THESE FUNDS
TO.
TO THEIR EXISTING FUNDS.
I HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT MORE
CLOSELY BEFORE I MAKE ANY TYPE
OF COMMITMENT. BUT WE WANT TO
WORK WITH ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO MOVE
ACCESS FORT AND EQUITY FOR.
OKAY SO I WOULD I WOULD WITHHOLD
MY MY VOTE TODAY JUST BASED ON
THAT TO WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE WE CAN GET
THAT DONE. HAVING ONE OF THE
DISTRICTS WHICH HAS MANY OF THE
STATE PARKS AND IT IT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE FOR THEM AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE THAT THE
FULL BEAUTY IN THE BOUNTY OF THE
STATE PARK. TO ALL PEOPLE.
I'M ON YOUR PAGE FOR THE
DISADVANTAGE AND I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE AN INABILITY
GET THERE AND I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE YOUTH. IN OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE THE ABILITY ARE TO TRAVEL
AND AND BE A PART OF THAT
EXPERIENCE AS WELL. AND AND I
KNOW THAT MANY OF THE SCHOOLS
AND RURAL AREAS HAVEN'T HAD THE
ABILITY TO HAVE FUNDS.
ARE AVAILABLE TO GO OUT AND BUY
SOME OF THESE NEW MODERN BUSES
AT THIS POINT. WHILE WHERE WE
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR IN HIS
BUDGET HE'S MADE A LOT OF MONEY
AVAILABLE BUT NOT ALL SCHOOLS
ARE ABLE TO COMPETE ON THE SAME
LEVEL. AND MORE THE URBANIZED
AREAS OF GOTTEN THOSE BUSES.
VERSUS A RURAL MOUNTAINOUS AREAS
SO THE KIDS WHO ARE THE CLOSEST
TO THE STATE PARKS DON'T GET TO
EXPERIENCE IT AS MUCH AS THOSE
ARE FARTHER AWAY.
BUT IT GOING BACK TO THE BUDGET
THE REAL BUDGET ISSUE HERE AND
ACROSS TO YOUR BILL. DOES.
APPROACH.
A DIFFICULTY FOR OUR STATE PARKS
TO PROVIDE THAT NECESSARY FUND.
SAYS
BECAUSE WHERE THEY'RE HAVING TO
TRAIN THEIR BUDGET SO I'D BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU MY
OFFICE WOULD BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU AND FINING RESOLUTION
TO THAT.
THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW MISTER
LIVING.
YEAH THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISS KOREA FOR
OFFERING THE BILL I LOVE THE
BILL. NOW IT'S HARD TO BRING
PARKS TO KIDS BUT WE CAN BRING
KIDS TO PARKS AND OUT RELIGIOUS
CHANGE.
THE SITUATION THAT WE HAVE NOW
WHERE.
HUGE POPULATIONS OF OUR STATE
NEVER GET TO EXPERIENCE THE
PARKING AND FEEL THAT THAT THAT
INTERCONNECTEDNESS THAT WE HAVE
WITH NATURE. AND THE NATURAL
BEAUTY OF OUR STATE AND THAT
THIS BILL REALLY HELPS US GET
THEIR I KNOW THAT THERE'S
CONCERNS ABOUT TECHNICALITIES OF
HOW WE DO IT BUT THE FACT THAT
WERE. MARCHING FORWARD TO BRING
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TWO CHILDREN AND I THINK
CHANGING THEIR LIVES BUT ALSO
CHANGING THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE
BY. ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A CONNECTION
TO THIS PLANET INTO TO THE STATE
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
THIS IS THE OVERARCHING GOAL
THAT WE SHOULD BE SHOOTING FOR.
SO THANKS FOR OFFER ARE OFFERING
THAT AND AND I'LL BE THERE TO
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHOI.
MOTION BY MISS RUBIO SECONDED BY
MISTER LEVINE.
MISTER CHOI. OH I. THOUGHT I HAD
A QUESTION BUT THAT THERE WAS A
VERY SIMILAR ALREADY THAT HAS
BEEN POSED DOT NOW REGARDING THE
BUDGET ISSUE WHETHER.
DE THE CREATION OF A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM WHETHER YOU HAD US
A SUDDEN SHE ENDINGS OF NO MIND
ABOVE NOW BUDGET THAT.
OR.
AN APPLICATION DAYS IS IS NOT
OPEN ENDED DOT THAT THOUGH YOU
MAY NOT KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
ALL WELL ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
APPLY FOR THAT A SOLO. WHETHER
YOU HAD ANY UP.
THEM BUDGET IDEA.
CERTAIN.
NEVER PLANNED SO FOR THAT
THOUGH SO THAT WAS SO MCCONNELL
RELATED.
NAM BUT THAT I THINK
IDEOLOGICALLY AS HAVE BUT IF YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL ANSWERS YOU
CAN ADD THAT. WHETHER YOU HAD
THE LOCK UP. MY NOSE TWENTY
THOUSAND FIVE IN THOUSAND
WHATEVER THAT YOU HAD A CERTAIN
PROGRAM. AND THAT THE OTHER ONE
IS THAT THERE ARE MANY SUCH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES SO. MANY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SO I KNOW UPON
REQUEST A SIMILAR PROGRAM.
GRANT PROGRAM L. WHEN YOU.
ILL APPLY AND THE MANY LOCAL
AGENCIES I HAVE WORKED TOGETHER
RATHER THAN STATE MANDATED. AND
ALSO AS YOU HEARD TELL OF A
TRILLION DOLLAR SELF LOVE BEFORE
THE MENTORS PROGRAM. AND THE
ISSA ASSESSED SLICE OF OUR
BUDGET. INFO WE SPEND AT THE
INDIA THE ONE WOULD HAVE TO
SUFFER.
SO.
IT IS SANTA
IN A BALANCING ACT. AND.
BUT THEY YOU HAD THE SECTORS
THAT CERTAIN SAID A MODEL
PROGRAM AND SO WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO
FIGURE IT OUT AND SO THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP. IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE BRING KIDS TO PARKS
AS MENTIONED BY MISTER LEVINE
PARKS CAN COME TO KIDS.
SO WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT OUT
AND SO WE'RE HOPING TO THAT THIS
BILL IS ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT.
MR GARCIA
I THINK YOU SCARED A TO THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
AS I WENT UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND THE PROCESS OF PUTTING
TOGETHER. COLLECTIVELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE WATER PARK
BONTA.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUESTHAT WAS RAISED OF COURSE
THE CONDITIONS OF OUR STATE
PARKS ARE BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
PARKS IN THE NEED TO. RENOVATE
BUILD.
WITH GREATER MAN SPACE RIGHT
THE DEFICIENCIES THAT EXIST UP
ANNOUNCED IN A CALIFORNIA TO THE
OPEN SPACE. BUT THE GUY
TRANSPORTATION GETTING ACCESS TO
AND FROM WAS ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES THAT WAS CAUSING REYES
AND SO I COMMEND YOU. OFFER
PUTTING THIS OUT PROPOSITION
FORWARD WERE ASKING THE NATURAL
RESOURCES TO DO AN ASSESSMENT.
RIGHT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT A WILL THE
POTENTIALLY REQUIRE US.
TO HAVE OUR.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS A PLAY A
BIGGER ROLE IN KIND OF EXPANDING
THE EDUCATIONAL. YOU KNOW.
ADVENTURES IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND LOOK IF IF
WHILE I WAS SERIOUS ABOUT THIS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A.
MORE THOROUGH CONVERSATION THEN
LET'S LET'S ASK OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO.
SPECIFICALLY MAKE A COMMITMENT
AND THE FUNDING MECHANISMS THAT
WE SENT TO THEM. ARM
TO SET ASIDE SOME SOME RESOURCES
TO RUN THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
I'M FULL IN FAVOR OF.
MOVING INTO THAT MAKES US
PHASE OF THE CONVERSATION IT
SOUNDS LIKE SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE I REPRESENT.
HAVE FOR MOST PARTY RURAL PART
OF.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA COACHELLA
IMPERIAL VALLEY AND THAT YOU
KNOW BUSING IS THE LARGEST PART
OF THEIR.
A BUDGET YOU KNOW EXPENSE BUT I
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE INTERESTED IN.
ASSURING THAT THEY'RE MAKING
GOOD USE OF THESE BUSES.
AND ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO VISIT JOSHUA TREE
WHICH IS ABOUT AN HOUR AND A
HALF AWAY FROM MY DISTRICT BUT I
WOULD GUESS THAT. NINETY PERCENT
OF THE CHILDREN THEY HAVE NEVER
BEEN THERE RIGHT AND SO I I.
COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COOPER WITH.
I M..
I WAS GONNA SAY I SUPPORT THE
MOTIVATION OF THIS BILL.
I ACTUALLY JUST RECENTLY I. WAS
READING AN ARTICLE ABOUT.
SOME KIDS FROM OAKLAND WHO
ACTUALLY WENT UP TO MOUNT
LASSEN.
WHICH IS NOT IN MY DISTRICT AND.
SALOON IN DALLAS DISTRICT BUT
I'VE I'VE HIKED LASSEN I MEAN
IT'S IT'S AN AWESOME EXPERIENCE
TO BE STANDING ON THE TOP OF
THAT. AND IT'S EXPERIENCE THAT
YOU KNOW YOU WANT YOU WANT A LOT
OF PEOPLE TO SEE AND. AND AND I
THINK EVEN YOU EVEN MORE BROADLY
LIKE. NEO SO MUCH OF PEOPLE IN
OUR MORE URBAN PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA GETTING OUT TO SEE
BOTH.
YOU KNOW THE SCENIC BEAUTY THE
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES BUT
ALSO SEEN YOU KNOW WHERE OUR
RESOURCES COME FROM WHERE WATER
COMES FROM WHERE AND. TIMBER
COMES FROM WHERE IN OUR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
COME FROM I THINK YOU KNOW IT IS
A GOOD THING SO I'M I'M SUPPORT
OF I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
AT TODAY THEM I THINK YOU HEARD
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT REALLY
REVOLVE AROUND THE BUDGETARY
ISSUES. AMONG THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE A KIND OF RESERVE MY
VOTE THERE BECAUSE I THINK WE DO
NEED TO WORK TO BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IS ADD TO.
WHAT IS ALREADY A PROBLEM IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC
WHICH IS A NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR BACKLOG IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND? I THINK MAYBE
THERE'S WAYS TO GET THERE THERE
IS SOME MONEY I KNOW AVAILABLE
THROUGH.
THE RECENT AIR RESOURCES BOARD
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
UPGRADING BUSES SO MAYBE THAT
COMPLAIN TO THIS AS WELL AND.
SO WITH THAT I'LL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS DAY BECAUSE I I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS A
GOOD THING WE SHOULD BE TRYING
TO GET MORE MORE PEOPLE OUT INTO
OR OUT DOORS ENCOURAGE THAT.
IT'S HUGE FROM A TOURISM
STANDPOINT I THINK IT'S JUST
GOOD FOR.
BEING A WELL ROUNDED PERSON
RIGHT.
SO. THAT SUPPORT THAT BUT LET'S
TRY TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
FISCALLY SHE'S RIGHT.
OKAY AT WITH THAT.
YET HIS REGULAR.
TO THE TO THE CHAIR.
THROUGH THE CHAIR TO THE CHAIR.
ON CENTER THE CO AUTHOR OF THIS
AND I I KNOW I ASKED.
THE AUTHOR OF THIS SO I I
THOUGHT I HEARD.
AND EXPRESS COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES ON THE BUDGET.
SIDE OF IT SO WE CAN FIND THE
FUNDING AND AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT TOUCH ON MY HEART A
GREAT DEAL. I'D BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
POLICY.
TO KEEP MOVING AND KEEP WORKING
ON ON RESOLVING THESE ISSUES
BUT.
AS I TO SIT IN APPROPRIATIONS
ALL HAVE TO RESERVE THAT AT THAT
MOMENT.
BUT I'D LIKE TO WORK WITH BOTH
OF YOU SO IF THERE'S A
COMMITMENT THERE I'M HAPPY TO
WORK ON TRYING TO PUSH THIS
FORWARD BOOK THAT MOST
DEFINITELY AT.
THERE'S A CAPTAIN YOU'RE LEADING
THE PACK HER SOLELY.
I'LL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE GOT
EVERYTHING ENDS OF COMMITMENT I
GOT YOUR SENSE THOUGH I I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ARE WITH THAT
WILL.
CALL THE ROLL THAT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS.
THE MOTION IS
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER AYE AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
AYE CARILLO AYE CHOI ABSTAINED.
NOT HOLDING.
CHOI NOT VOTING.
TWO OTHER.
TWO I FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA.
LEVINE AYE AYE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
OF THOSE MATHIS NOT VOTING
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SOLIS WOULD.
RIGHT WE KEEP BECAUSE. IT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SOME MEMBER OF THE
MONTH.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR.
THINK YOU TURN MEMBERS AND.
I BRING TO YOU AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR AND IT'S A VERY
SIMILAR A CONCEPT BUT ITS NOT
IDENTICAL AND I THINK THE LAST
BILL YOU HEARD WAS REALLY AROUND
TRANSPORTATION AND THIS IS.
ABOUT CREATING AND EQUITY GRANT
FUNDING PROGRAM. A FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION IN ORDER TO INCREASE
THE ABILITY.
ABILITY TO UNDERSERVED AN T
RISK POPULATIONS TO PARTICIPATE
IN OUTDOOR. ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM SO I JUST
WANNA AT MAKE SURE THAT WE THOSE
ARE CLEAR THAT ONE IS REALLY
LOOKING AT TRANSPORTATION AND
ONE IS A GRANT PROGRAM.
MORE HOLISTICALLY BECAUSE THE
COSTS ARE JUST LIMITS
TRANSPORTATION.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATIONS TO GIVE PRIORITY
FOR FUNDING FOR OUTDOOR
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS NORTHERN
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT PRIMARILY THAT PRIMARY
TARGET UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
AT CALIFORNIA HAS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY STATE PARKS AND MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF PUBLIC LAND THAT
EXHIBIT THE NATURAL BEAUTY AND
HISTORY OF OUR STATE IN ADDITION
TO EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
ACCESS TO SUCH OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES HOWEVER ARE OFTEN.
ON HARD TO REACH FOR COMMUNITIES
AND STUDENTS IN LOW INCOME AND
OTHER NOT AN OTHERWISE
MARBLEIZED AREAS IN THE STATE
WITH ME AND I HAVE JOSE GONZALEZ
FOUNDER OF THAT LATINO OUTDOORS.
AND AND ALSO KAREN DRIVE MOST
FOUNDER OF GET OUT STAY OUT AND
HAD TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AYE KAREN AT IS ALSO
AVAILABLE US. TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS LEYVA.
WHO WOULD LIKE WHAT SORRY YOU'RE
ANSWERING THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE A?
I GOOD MORNING WITH THE CHAIR
AND.
.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KAREN THOMAS AND I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF GET OUT STAY
OUT. IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE MOANS AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR. CANNOT STAY OUT OF
THE FIVE ONE THREE THREE NON
PROFIT DEDICATING TO DEDICATED
TO PROVIDING OUTDOOR EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO YOUTH AND
CHILDREN ON THE CENTRAL COAST.
A THROUGH HIKING CAMPING AND
WILL TAKE A BACKPACKING
EXPERIENCES.
A WE BELIEVE THAT THE OPERATIVE
BY THE IDEAL AND UNIQUE TOOLS.
.
TO BUILD SELF CONFIDENCE AND
DEVELOP LEADERSHIP SKILLS
OUR WORK PRIMARILY FOCUSES ON
THE INDIGENOUS MIGRANT
POPULATIONS. NOWADAYS THESE
COUPLE TECH IN THE MIX THAT CAN
THE MY IN THE TIKI COMMUNITIES.
AND MANY OTHERS INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE U. S..
I THIS PAST YEAR GET OUT THAT
WAS ABLE TO SUPPORT OVER A
HUNDRED YOUTH.
I IN THEIR OUT TO ENDEAVORS BUT
NOT WITHOUT THE HELP OF MOVEMENT
LIKE AB TWENTY. FOUR.
AS BILLS IMPORTED UP BECAUSE
THE ALLOCATE FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS SHAPING THE
FUTURE LEADERS ADVOCATES AND
ENVIRONMENTALIST OF OUR COUNTRY.
OF FOR THESE REASONS GET UP THEY
OUT STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR. AND THANKFUL
TO A FAMILY MEMBER THE MOANS
LIMON FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
ON THE MATTER AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
HER AGAIN MISTER CHAIR.
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GONNA MY NAME'S JOSE GONZALEZ
AND THE FOUNDER OF LATINO DOORS.
I'VE THIS YEAR BEFORE WERE
UNIQUELY DINA LATINO LET THE
NEXT COM THAT OF ANY STATION.
VOLUNTEER POWERED ALSO.
.
ESPECIALLY BASED IN A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT. WE TEND TO USE
THE WORD UNDERREPRESENTED BUT
REALLY IT'S KIND UNDERSERVED IN
A VARIETY OF WAYS.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS THAT OUR
VOLUNTEER LEADERS PROVIDED SENDS
AN OUTING OUTDOOR EXPERIENCE.
THERE'S HOW THE LOGISTICAL AND
TECHNICAL ASPECT THAT WE
MENTIONED BEFORE. I'M AN
IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY TO THE
STATE.
AND MY FIRST TRANSFORMATIVE
EXPERIENCE WAS IS IN CALAVERAS
THAT BIG TREES.
HOUSE I GREW UP IN TURLOCK
RIGHTS MACINNES AND CENTRAL
VALLEY I DO NOT KNOW I HAD SUCH
MAJESTY JESS AND OUR TWO AWAY
AND GET OUT TO ASSEMBLY UNTIL I
WAS IN COLLEGE EVEN THOUGH
THAT'S ALSO.
TWO PLUS HOURS AWAY.
IN HAVING THOSE EXPERIENCES YOU
KNOW THAT HAPPENED NOT JUST
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO GO ON MY
OWN OR BECAUSE MY PARENTS COULD
ACTUALLY JUST TAKE ME. IT
HAPPENED WITH COMMUNITY SUPPORT
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SCHOOLS YEAH IT GOT THERE.
THROUGH THE HELP OF OUR.
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING OUTREACH CATION ON
A SCHOOL BUS.
IN THIS OUTING EXPERIENCE IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE.
FOR US IN TERMS OF A LATINO
IDENTITY AND CULTURE.
FIRST OF ALL IT'S WELCOME TO
EVERYBODY SO THERE'S NO
EXCLUSIVITY AROUND THAT JUST TO
BE CLEAR. BUT KNOWING THAT.
THAT LEADERSHIP IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE TAKING OUT
IS CRUCIAL AND IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE BOTH OF THE PARTICIPANTS
ARE ABLE TO FEEL LIKE IF THEY
CAN REPRESENT THE FULL SELVES.
AND THEY'RE GOING AN OUT
EXPERIENCES WITH THOSE THAT ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT LIVED
EXPERIENCE.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
I CONSIDER MYSELF A A MODEL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND AND YOU
A CITIZEN.
I IN A WAY THAT I CAN. NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE TRADITIONAL OUTDOOR
CONSERVATION SPACE.
BUT ALSO ABLE TO LEVERAGE MEDINA
IDENTITY TO A BIT MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS AND BRIDGE THAT
NOTHING THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BEING ABLE
TO SUPPORTING CREATE MORE AND
THE CULTURAL LEADERS. THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO BRIDGE
THIS.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW THERE'S STILL MANY
EXAMPLES WHERE EXISTING PROGRAMS
INFRASTRUCTURE MAKES IT
DIFFICULT NOT TO DO THIS.
ARE WE ALREADY KNOW FROM BEFORE
A. B. AT THIRTEEN THIRTY.
ALSO THE ACADEMIC IMPACT THAT
OUT TO EXPERIENCES CAN HAVE.
AND SO HAD KNOWING THAT THE
OUTDOOR SUPPLY OF ACADEMIC.
ESPECIALLY SCIENCE GAINES.
CULTURAL CONNECTION BUT ALSO TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT THE.
STEWARDSHIP
COMPONENT AND NOT JUST BE ABLE
TO GO AND APPRECIATE OUR STATE
OUR PUBLIC LANDS STATE AND
FEDERAL AND STATE PARKS BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THESE WHAT IS
IT TAKE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S.
WHAT'S BEING HERE BEYOND THE
EXPERIENCE OF TRUMP THE
LANDSCAPE THE PRESERVATION THE
STEWARDSHIP NOT A CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THAT'S WHY.
.
CONTACT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
FOR LEADERSHIP IN THIS IN AS THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR. HA
BECAUSE WE NEED THIS KIND OF
PROCESS AN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING FUNDING
SUPPORT TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
THERE WAS THOSE EARLY
TRANSFORMATIVE EXPERIENCES THAT
ALLOWED ME TO BE WHERE I AM
TODAY AND BE ABLE TO DO THE WORK
THAT I DO IN SERVICE OF THAT SO
THANK YOU.
BOTH THE BUREAU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT.
STEVE BAKER WITH TEN STRANDS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS WITH THE TRADITIONAL
SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY. IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SECURITY TOM
RAFTER CAN WITH THE SPORTFISHING
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MERSEYSIDE
GONZALEZ POTTER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAHOE ALLIANCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN FORCE COUNCIL
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS HOLLY
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
JIM JUST MULLIN FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES.
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LEN ORTIZ ON BEHALF
OF BOOKS ARE LATIN LAND TRUST
AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY OF THE
SPACE OF THIRTY AND SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RECALL MONSTER TO
NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND. IN SUPPORT I APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP ON
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE OF GIVING
DISADVANTAGED YOUNG PEOPLE. AN
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCE IN THIS IS
ANOTHER BILL THAT LEADS TO A
WELL ROUNDED HUMAN BEINGS.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FRENCH MAKER
BEHALF OF THE WILDLINGS
CONSERVANCY AND SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE AND SUPPORT.
WHAT ELSE?
WISHING.
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
ANY. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO I STARED.
YEAH AND NOW IT'S OUT OF YOUR
HERE FOR THE PREVIOUS VOWED TO
MAKE THE SAME CAVEAT I MEAN
DEFTLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
AND I THINK WE JUST NEED TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE FISCAL
ISSUES AND. AND CERTAINLY WE
WANT PEOPLE TO GO TO WE WANT
PEACE. EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT PARKS AND HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PARKS ARE WELL
MAINTAINED SO.
I THINK IT'S TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH AND FIGURE OUT THE
FISCAL ISSUES GOING FORWARD IS
IS REALLY THE ISSUE.
FOR SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT I JUST
KIND OF I'M GUESSING AT SOMEBODY
ELSE'S QUESTION MIGHT BE AROUND
AT THAT A TOPIC AND YES WE I
THINK IT THERE IS AN AGREEMENT.
THAT AND YOU KNOW OUR OUR PARKS.
ARE ALREADY AN IMPORTANT AND I
THINK ASSET TO OUR STATE AND SO
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR TAX
HEAVILY AND THEY HAVE. DONE IT
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET
TO DO THIS BUT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO KIND OF EXPLORE THIS I'M IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PREVIOUS
FEEL THAT YOU JUST HEARD.
AWARE ALSO COMMITTED TO LOOK AT
ELENI ELIGIBLE SPECIAL FUND
RESOURCES WHETHER AND ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FIND
OR. AND YOU KNOW THE SPECIAL
PARKS AND REX I FIND SO WE ARE
AT COMMITTED TO EXPLORING HOW WE
WOULD MAKE THIS A REALITY AND WE
WOULD HOPE THAT WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT IN THE POLICY LEVEL BUT
ABSOLUTELY.
UNDERSTAND THAT THE FISCAL
IMPACT ON AND THE ABILITY TO DO
THIS IS REALLY I'VE PENDING ON
WHERE THE RESOURCES I COULD COME
FROM WITH OUT. ALREADY AND YOU
KNOW TAXING.
A VERY LIMITED SOURCE OF FUNDS.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
A I DO.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE KIDS THAT
DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
GO ANYWHERE UNTIL LATER IN LIFE
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE. UP WHAT
YOU'RE DOING WITH THIS AND THINK
FOR BEING THE BILL FOR THE.
SOME MEMBER BILL. I WAS JUST
GONNA WANNA MAKE SURE I I THINK
YOU'VE ADDRESSED THE QUESTION
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT. THE
STATE PARKS ARE FUNDED IN THREE
MECHANISMS
GENERAL FUND USER FEES AND FROM
STATE US SPECIAL FUNDS.
AND THE SPECIAL FUNDS CAN BE A
PLETHORA OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
FROM RENTING STATE LANDS AND AND
WHAT ARE NOT.
THE REAL THE REAL CRUX OF THE
ISSUE IS WHEN WE START TALKING
ABOUT TAKING FROM OTHER FEES AND
OTHER FUNDS.
WE'RE HAMPERING THEIR ABILITIES
TO BE SUCCESSFUL
SO THE GENERAL FUND BECOMES. THE
SOLE SOURCE FOR REALLY THE NEXT
ALL OF FUNDING THING IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO
IDENTIFY.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET THE FUNDS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE THESE PROGRAMS
SUCCESSFUL ON WITH?
MISTER GALLAGHER AND AND MANY
THE MEMBERS AROUND HERE AND WITH
YOU IN CONCEPT WE WANT TO GET
THE EXPERIENCE THERE SO.
I WANNA BE SUPPORTIVE I JUST
WENT OVER THE FUNDS ARE COMING
FROM SO I CAN GET THERE AND WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU WE AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THAT'S WHAT
SOMETHING THAT IS NEEDED. AND
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE WE
DON'T WANT TO I'D JUST THINK OF
THAT YOU KNOW JUST GENERAL FUND
ITSELF AND SO WE WERE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE OTHER SPECIALS THAT
WERE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO TRY
TO WORK.
ON THIS IN TERMS OF MOVING
FORWARD.
NEW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE MOTION BY SOME OF
CHIU AND MRS RUBIO CLOSING
COMMENTS EXPECT LAST WHEN I HAVE
IT RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AT CLEARLY THERE SEEMS
TO BE A.
A TREND HERE RIGHT THAT THAT
WERE WANTING TO BRING GREATER
AXES TO.
UNDERSERVED UP POPULATIONS OF
THE STATE TO OUR OUTDOORS AND.
LOOK WE WE'VE MADE A A
SUBSTANTIAL REQUEST OF.
ARE BUDGET CHAIRS AND.
THIS GOVERNOR TO INVEST IN OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCIES.
WE'VE MAY REQUEST IN THE AMOUNT
OF ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF MONIES THAT ARE BEING
GENERATED FROM THE HAD
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FINE
AND WE THINK THAT.
THESE TYPES OF PRIORITIES THAT
ARE BEING DISCUSSED MERIT. YOU
KNOW A SERIOUS CONSIDERATION AND
SO THERE IS NOT ONLY THE POLICY.
DELIBERATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
BUT I THINK THERE ARE AVENUES TO
FUND THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND
IF JULIE. I THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR THIS BODY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
I AM WERE HAPPY TO GENERATE.
LETTER GET SOME SIGNATURES ON
IT AND A RESUBMIT SOMETHING TO
YOU KNOW THE BUDGET CHAIRS AND
ALL THE WAY. THROUGH THE PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE LINE
AGAIN THE POLICY WITH THE
RESOURCES. THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
FULFILL.
THESE EFFORTS SO JUST WHY SAY
THAT THAT.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT DATA OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO REALLY MEET THESE
OBJECTIVES OF.
I THINK YOU INTO A SECTOR FOR
VOCAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHIU ARE
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA.
HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA LEVINE BY LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING. RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE SALT.
SOLACE I WOULD.
IT WILL KEEP THE.
ROLE OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS TO
ADD ON BREAK YOU THINK IF.
WE HAVE NO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PRESENT THAT.
IT WAS BIGELOW JULY TO OUR
PRESENT.
AND DIE I WOULD DIE BEFORE HE
PRESENTS A TAKE A MOTION ON THE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITSELF
MOTION BY MISTER MATHIS SECOND
BY MISTER HARPER.
AND SAW SO.
WILL NOT TAKE ACTION THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND THEN WILL HAVE.
PRESENTATION OF SECTOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FLATLY BEES NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FIVE.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
I PUT BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. CHOI.
CHU. CHU AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA.
HARPER.
HARPER I.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SOLACE.
SOLACE I WOULD.
LEAVE THAT OPEN ALSO FURTHER
COLLEAGUES AT ON SOME MEMBER
CLOSURES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT ZERO FIVE. REGARDING THE
MANAGEMENT OF WILD PIGS THIS
MEASURE WAS DEVELOPED FROM
RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDED BY A
REPORT FROM THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION AFTER SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS.
THAT WERE HELD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WILD PIGS ARE A NON NATIVE
INVASIVE SPECIES RESIDING IN
FIFTY
SIX OVER FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
IMPORTANTLY THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. BETTER MANAGE WILD
PIGS AND MITIGATE THE DAMAGE
THEY CAUSE TO LANDOWNERS. AND
ARE ENDANGERED SPECIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND I'M.
WORKING AND ALSO WORKING WITH
MY STAFF I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE VOLUNTARY REPORTING FOR
THE TAKE OF A WILD PIG.
JOINING ME TODAY IS MISTER ROY
GRIFFITH.
WITH TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF GAME
WARDEN EXPERIENCE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND WELL KRAMER'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. AND
OUTFIT FEDERATION AND I'M SORRY
MARKET WE CAN MARK WATERFALL
THANK YOU MARKEDLY FROM THE
WATER FELL.
MEMBERS.
WHEN IT'S TIME I WOULDA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. BILL.
SECOND. VERSA WHAT.
RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE AND AS.
SOON A MEMBER BIGELOW SAYS MY
TIME WITH THE DEPARTMENT THAT I.
DEVELOP A FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE
OF THE BIG PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE DAMAGE TO HABITAT ON
THEIR DIRECT COMPETITION WITH
NATIVE WILDLIFE.
I REPRESENTS THE RPA THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND THAT'S OUR GOAL
IT'S YOUR PA TO. TO TURN AS MANY
THESE DEPREDATION PIGS AND A
HARVESTABLE PICKS AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
MISTER BIGELOW ON THIS.
THIS BILL AND IT IS A GOOD
VEHICLE FOR DOING THAT.
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE PIGS
ARE HIGHLY SOUGHT AFTER GAME
ANIMAL
AT THEM IN THE SAME TIME THEY
CREATE. YOU KNOW AND PROVEN
DAMAGE TO HABITAT.
THE PIGS ARE LOCATED IN FIFTY
EIGHT A FIFTY SIX OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY BRING IN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EACH YEAR IN REVENUE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT THROUGH THE
TICKET PURCHASES SELLS THESE
TAGS.
HOWEVER SWITCHING FROM THE PIG
TAG TO PICK STAMP WE BELIEVE
WILL ACTUALLY INCREASE REVENUE
WE BELIEVE WILL INCREASE ACCESS
FOR THE EVER AVERAGE HUNTER TOO.
EASY MORE EASILY ARE HOT AND
HARVEST THESE PIGS.
.
SO OUR.
PLAY.
ARE WE REALLY.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THAT TO
WILD THAT WITH THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER FOR TWO WAS THE OUT
WILDLIFE RESOURCE COMMITTEE.
AND.
THAT HAS BEEN VETTED FOR OVER A
YEAR SO REALLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NO KRAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I WON I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
DEALING WITH WILD PIGS ARE NON
NATIVE AND CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
DAMAGE BOTH THE PRIVATE PROPERTY
IN OUR STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BUT A VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUE TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE'S.
INTERESTS ARE CONSIDERED AND WE
COME UP WITH THE RIGHT SOLUTION.
AND WE THINK.
AB TWENTY TO FIVE A WILL
ULTIMATELY DO THAT THERE'S STILL
A FEW TWEAKS THAT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE AND TO MAKE SURE THAT. THERE
AREN'T ANY IMPACTS ON OUR
DOMESTIC.
PORK PRODUCTION IN THROUGH THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS A WILD
PIG.
BUT WE THINK THAT THIS BILL BY
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT FOR OUR
MEMBERS TO GET A DEPREDATION
PERMIT FOR THESE PIGS THAT ARE
CAUSING DAMAGE. WILL BE HELPFUL
IN TRYING TO ULTIMATELY REDUCE
THE POPULATION AND ON MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF WILD PIGS AND WE
WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
AND THERE MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THE COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL. YOU REALLY
LIKE THE ARE RECENT CHANGES TO
THE BILL.
ARE THE BILL REDUCES THE PIG FOR
A TAG OR EXCUSE ME PIC
VALIDATION TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS
WHICH HELPS ADDRESS COSTS COST
IS A BARRIER TO HUNTING FOR SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS.
ON THE FUNDING GENERATED ALSO
STILL GOES TO OUR BIG GAME
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT WHICH VERY
IMPORTANT.
SUPPORTING CONSERVATION
PROGRAMS.
AND WE.
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE DE LINKAGE
TO THE SHARE PROGRAM THAT'S A
PRIVATE LANDS ACCESS PROGRAM.
THAT PROVIDES A PUBLIC CUNNEEN
OPPORTUNITIES ON FARM AND OTHER
PRIVATE LANDS ALL DONE IN A
LANDOWNER FRIENDLY WAY IT'S A
WIN WIN FOR FARMERS AND
SPORTSMEN SO. WE APPRECIATE THAT
LINKAGE AND URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
BACK ON THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS WANT TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR THE BILL AT MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE MEMBERS POLIO TO
SHUDDER AND TO HAVE THE PLEASURE
COUNTY BOARD SOUP RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL NEXT.
JIM WHAT A MEASURE CHAIRMAN.
JIM WATERS WITH GAINS IN
ASSOCIATION GAINES AND
ASSOCIATES LIKE TO REPRESENT
THE.
THE CALIFORNIA WETLAND IN WATER
FELL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA OF.
HUNT BOWMAN HUNTERS IN STATE
ARTERY ASSOCIATION THE BY A
PRACTICE.
BACK.
BLACK BRANT A GROUP.
AND THE SUSAN RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT PURCHASE
SUPPORT.
WHAT ELSE?
OKAY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WANT TO SPEAK.
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS STEWARD
DOLLAR.
AND REPRESENTING THE MODESTO
HELMSMAN.
AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE NOT
UNSYMPATHETIC TO PROPERTY
OWNERS.
AND THE LOW.
LAND DAMAGING PROPERTY.
TO LOS TO THEIR CROPS.
WE'RE STANDING IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
BECAUSE.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
POPULATION OF WILD PIG IS IN THE
STATE.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A STEADY SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
TO ESTABLISH HOW MANY PIGS THERE
ARE IN THIS STATE.
DO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN.
TAKE
DROPPED BY EIGHT POINT THREE
PERCENT.
SO WE'RE REALLY ASKING THAT A
MANAGEMENT STUDY.
BE ENACTED BEFORE.
WE CHANGE.
THE CURRENT STATUS.
OF THE PIG AS A BIG GAME ANIMAL
TO AN EXOTIC AND WHAT IN THE
WORLD AS AN EXOTIC MEAN ANYWAY.
MEAN WEBSTER DICTIONARY
DESCRIBES THAT AS A STRIKINGLY
DIFFERENT.
ARE.
A DISTINGUISHING. UNUSUAL
ANIMAL.
AND.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS GOING TO DESCRIBE A
FERAL PIG HAS
STRIKINGLY UNUSUAL.
ALSO WITHIN THIS BILL THERE IS
NO PROVISION FOR THE USE OF DOGS
NOW THAT'S MY PATIENT AS A HOUND
MEN.
AND THERE IS NO PROVISION FOR
THE USE OF DOGS.
EVEN THOUGH IT SAYS BY ANY
MEANS.
EVERY TIME IT SAYS SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HOUND. WERE LEFT SHORT SO.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE'RE SIMPLY
ASKING.
THAT YOU COULD.
TWO OF THE WITNESSES DOT DOT
MANY OF CO CHAIRMAN OF THE
COALITION OF ALL. ODDS CHAPTERS
OF ASCII AS WELL AS CHAPTER
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO SUPPORT
A CLUB.
WE OPPOSE THE GAME STATUS BEING
TAKEN AWAY FROM WILD PIGS.
BUT A GAME STATUS SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN.
IT'S A VIABLE AFFORDABLE BANG
FOR A CALIFORNIANS TO HAUNT.
.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WAS THE
LAST SURVEY DONE.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PUT INTO THE BUDGET FOR.
FISHING WILDLIFE I THINK THAT
THEY COULD DO A STUDY TO TELL US
WHETHER WE HAVE TOO MANY YOU NOT
ENOUGH WHERE. OF PICKED BOB
PROBLEMS OCCUR AND HOW THEY
SHOULD BE MANAGED.
OF.
BECOME WILDLIFE IS WHAT.
SHOULD BE CONTROLLING OUR.
WHILE I POPULATION AND THEY
HATED IT SHOULD ARE.
TITLE TO BE DOING THEIR JOB.
KATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA BE VERY BRIEF.
I DID PARTICIPATE AT THE WRC AT
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
HOWEVER THAT PROCESS WAS THAT.
AS WAS POINTED OUT A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THE LAST
WILD PIG MANAGEMENT STUDY THAT
WAS DONE WAS DONE IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE UP A COPY OF IT HERE
I ACTUALLY HAD ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT FOR A COPY THEY HAD
TO DIG IT OUT OF THEIR ARCHIVES.
THIS WAS NEVER EVEN MENTIONED IN
THE PROCEEDINGS AT THE WRC IN
THIS IS. THAT THIS WAS A FIVE
YEAR PLAN AT THE TIME AND
THERE'S A STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
SECTION FORTY SIX FIFTY ONE OF
THE FISH AND GAME CODE. THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO DO A MANAGEMENT
PLAN SO WHILE WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE OBJECTIVE THAT MISTER
BIGELOW IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WERE ALSO SUPPORTIVE. OF.
AGRICULTURE HAVING RELIEF FROM
DEPREDATION WE DO NOT SEE MERIT
IN REMOVING THE GAME STATUS WE
THINK THE GAME STATUS SHOULD BE
PRESERVED. YOU CAN LOOSEN UP THE
DEPREDATION REQUIREMENTS.
AND SINCE THAT WAS REFERENCED
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF MONEY
FROM THE PIC TAG PROGRAM IT
SEEMS ONLY REASONABLE THAT THE
MONEY BE USED FOR PEGS AND THAT
THE MANAGEMENT PLAN BE UPDATED.
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
OUR DEPARTMENT OR COMMISSION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SUMMER MATH.
MISTER BIGELOW I THINK YOU HAVE
A GREAT BILL HERE LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
SAUCE.
THANK YOU AT THINK RECIPROCAL
LARGE SAID A COUPLE OF.
QUESTION IF YOU JUST COMMENT ON
SOME OF THE.
POINTS RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
IN WHAT YOU'RE DOING KNOW EITHER
WORK WITH THEM OR ARE YOU BE ON
THAT PLANE AND THE BILL IS WHAT
IT IS.
FETCHED LIKE UPDATE ON ON THOSE
EFFORTS PLEASE
THE LATTER POINT WERE ALWAYS
WILLING TO WORK WITH WITH FOLKS
TO TRY TO RESOLVE AND GET THE
BEST DEAL POSSIBLE. FOR ALL
PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED BY THIS
WITH RESPECT TO THE FIRST
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE ABOUT THE
THE DOGS AND HOUNDS. TO BE ABLE
TO HIDE WE'RE NOT TOUCHING ANY
PART OF THE BILL THEY HAVE THE
SAME EXISTING RIGHTS THAT
THEY'VE HAD.
FOR AS LONG AS THEY'VE HAD
RIGHTS TO HUNT THERE NAMED IN
ANOTHER SECTION OF THE LAWS A
WEEK WE ARE SILENT ON THAT IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE THE IT ALREADY
EXISTS THERE'S NO NEED TO.
APPROACH THAT WITH RESPECT TO.
MS LYNCH'S A COMMENTS I THINK
WHERE.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HER AND ADDRESS A AS MUCH
AS WE CAN.
AT SOME POINT YOU JUST HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE ITS TIME TO MOVE ON.
AND PUT A BILL FORD I THINK WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE STUDIES
THOUGH AND WE LOOK AT THE
REALITIES THERE'S A NUMBER
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
ONE MILLION EXISTING PICKS.
THAT EXISTS BE AND FIFTY SIX OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TODAY.
THE HARM.
THAT'S BEING DONE TO BOTH
FARMING.
PRIVATE LINES PRIVATE YARDS.
TO OUR GOLF COURSES IS IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FAR
MORE THAN THE FIND GENERATES
INPUTS BACK.
TO MANAGE I THINK WE CAN DO
BETTER.
WITH THIS AS IT'S OUTLINED
TODAY I WOULD ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU
THAT THINK MISTER REGLA I'LL
TRUST YOUR FORCES THIS CONTINUES
TO MOVE FORWARD.
LOOK FORWARD TO OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE SEVERAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE BUT. YES.
.
BUT TRUST JUNE THE JEWEL FULFILL
AND WORK THROUGH THOSE EFFORTS I
WILL AND IF ONE NOTE JUST FOR
EVERYONE.
I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS THAT IT
DEPICTS CAN REGENERATE EVERY
THREE MONTHS THREE WEEKS AND
THREE DAYS.
ARE THE AVERAGE SIX PIGLETS IN
THE WILD. OTHERS MORE THAN TEN.
AND WHEN YOU'RE DOING I'M IN A I
DOMESTICATED LA OUTCOME SO YOU
CAN LITERALLY TAKE THE
POPULATION.
AND TRIPLE IT EACH YEAR.
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT.
EVEN IF YOU TOOK SEVENTY
PERCENT.
AS A KILL RATE.
YOU STILL HAVE YOU WILL BE
GAINING IN THE POPULATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BEFORE
ALREADY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THAT
MAGIC NUMBER OF.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND A
MILLION HAD.
WE HAVE A CRISIS PROBLEM WITH
OVERPOPULATION AND DAMAGE THAT'S
CAUSED BY THEIR ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER JOURNAL SOME
NUMBER A KALRA HAS QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
YOU SOME OF THE SUMMER BIGELOW I
BELIEVE IT OR NOT AT BEING IN
SAN JOSE INFORMATION MIGHT
MEMBER THIS WE ACTUALLY HAVE HAD
A LOT OF ISSUES. WITH WHILE
PICKS. UP TO CLEAN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF OUR CITY AND AND COMING
INTO NEIGHBORHOODS WITH YARDS IN
OUR CITY PARKS WITH THAT AND I
THINK THAT. I'M I ALSO WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THIS
MOVES FORWARD AND CERTAINLY OF
DFW COMING UP BUT THE MANAGEMENT
PLAN I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL PUT
INPUT INTO AND ALSO HERE FOR
SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
CONCERNS AS WELL BUT. I
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING YOUR TIME
MANAGING THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PREVIOUS
MEMBER THAT REPRESENT THE AREA.
TO FONG WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE.
AND AND OTHERS FROM THE AREA
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THIS IN
THE PAST AS I'VE TRIED WORK IT
THROUGH AND MY CONTINUED SUPPORT
FROM THEM CONTINUES NOW AND INTO
THE FUTURE.
NO QUESTIONS.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION BY SUMMER
MATHIS AND SOME MEMBER RUBIO.
.
TAKE THAT AS A CLOSING THANK SIR
MEMSIC TRIP PLEASE CALL ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
I BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI ARE AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
TO AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GLORIA.
HARPER.
BOB. HERTZBERG NOT VOTING.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE AYE LEVINE
AYE MATHIS.
BY MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
SOLACE I WOULD.
LEAVE THAT OLD RECALL MEMBERS AT
ON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SEVENTY.
MS YOU MOVES.
YOU'D THINK.
ALONE.
YOU.
I WAS ACTUALLY CAUGHT UP HERE
BECAUSE I. DIDN'T.
IS FILE WATER BUT I DID CALL
THEM UP THAT'S MY. MISTAKE I
POLITICS.
BUT VERY BIG IF THIS YEAR IS
GOOD MORNING.
.
ACHIEVEMENT MEMBERS.
I.
THESE PEOPLE PLEASE BE BRIEF.
I WILL BE BRIEF.
FOR TWENTY YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A STEADY HAS SEEN A STEADY
DECLINE OF HUNTERS THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE BECAUSE SENATOR
KITA WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT OF THE
PRINCIPAL SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
CONSERVATION EFFORTS ON THE
REVENUE THEY GENERATE. WE COULD
NOT MANAGE OUR FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY COMPLIMENTING
SEED THAT DFW IS ONGOING CONTRA
RECRUITMENT RETENTION
REACTIVATION EFFORTS.
PATHETICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH TO FREE HUNTING DAYS
PER YEAR WHERE AN UNLICENSED
HUNTER CAN GO OUT AND HUNT JUST
FOR THAT DAY ONCE A YEAR WITH A
LICENSE UNDER. THE IDEA
ORIGINATED WITH SENATOR HOLLINGS
WORTH IN TWO THOUSAND TEN HIS
BILL AUTHORIZES THE DIRECTOR OF
CDF W. TO DECLARE FREE HUNTING
DAYS IN THE FALL AND IN THE
WINTER. WAS MODELED ON
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING FREE
FISHING DAYS UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE THE BILL PASSING
UNANIMOUSLY CDF W. HAS YET TO
DECLARE A SINGLE FREE HUNTING
DAY. THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE DIRECTOR DECLARE TO
SUCH DAYS PER YEAR. ASSET
FOURTEEN SENATOR HOLLINGS WITH
LEGISLATION TO PARTICIPATE ONE
MUST BE ACCOMPANIED BY A LICENSE
AN EXPERIENCED HUNTER AND IT
COMPLETED A HUNTER SAFETY
EDUCATION OUR COURSE HERE TO.
TESTIFY AS TO THE BENEFITS OF A
FREE HUNTING DAYS I HAVE WITH ME
MARC HEADLEY OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND REALLY
GRIFFITH OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON THE BILL.
I MISSED CHAIR MARKEDLY
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
TWAS THE TWENTY THOUSAND MEMBER
NONPROFIT DEBT CARRIES OUT
HUNTER EDUCATION RECRUITMENT
PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ESSENTIALLY TO TRY
BEFORE THEY BUY WITH THEIR
HUNTING LICENSE
HUNTING LICENCES AND.
IN CALIFORNIA I AM AMONG THE
MOST EXPENSIVE OF ANY STATE WE
KNOW THAT COSTS CAN BE A BARRIER
TO PARTICIPATION INITIALLY.
SO THIS BILL HELPS TO ADDRESS
THAT.
AS WAS.
MENTIONED EARLIER BY PROVIDING
AN INCENTIVE BEHIND THIS IS
GOING TO COMPLIMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S HUNTER RECRUITMENT.
RETENTION REACTIVATION PROGRAMS.
AND THEN.
BY DOING THAT AND GETTING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE OUTDOORS AYE
IT'S CAN ALTERNATELY GENERATE
MORE FUNDING FOR WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION. TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE GENERATED THROUGH
HUNTING FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES.
AND THEY'RE ALL JUST OUT ONE.
QUICK THING DOWN THERE'S A
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT
DELAYS IMPLEMENTATION TELL JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
SHE GIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE PLENTY OF TIME TO
GET THE SET UP. SO THANK YOU.
READY.
GOOD MORNING WHICH GERMAN
MEMBERS ROY GRIFFITH AS.
BOB WITH CALVIN RIFLE PISTOL
SOCIALISM BUT TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HUNTERS CONSERVATION COALITION
WHICH IS COALITION OF MANY OF
AND OUR MEMBERS HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS MARK MENTIONED HUNTING
BILLING BRINGS IN A HUNTING
LICENSE ALONE OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA. COMBINED THAT WITH
TAG SALES TWENTY SIX MILLION.
PITTMAN ROBERTSON DOLLARS ELEVEN
PERCENT EXCISE TAX THAT HUNTERS
PLAY ON THE SPORTING GOODS AND
AMMUNITION BRINGS ANOTHER FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
FOR CONSERVATION EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA. SORIANO HUNTERS HAVE
TAKEN CARE OF WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT.
THE GOVERNOR EVEN RECOGNIZE THIS
BILL AS WE TALKED ABOUT THE OUR
THREE AFTER RECRUITMENT
RETENTION REACTIVATION TO THE
POINT THAT HE MENTIONED IN THE
BUDGET IS LINE ITEMS. THAT ARE
IN SPENDING CONSERVATION EFFORTS
IMPROVING HUNTING AND FISHING
PARTICIPATION AND CONNECTING
MORE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
OUTDOORS IN THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT.
HUNTERS TO PAY THEIR PART AND
IT'S IT'S TIME THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AND GET MORE INVOLVED AS
MARK MENTIONED TRIBE FOR DIVIDE
IS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER
STATES.
SO WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT BUT
NOT IMPLEMENTING THAT HERE.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE DO WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS AND JUST BEEN GOING
DOWNHILL FOR YEARS SO REALLY
ENCOURAGE. YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GIVEN BONUSES CHAIR
OF PRIVILEGES TAKEN SOME GOOD
NOTES ON YOUR BILL INTO.
SMALLER RECOGNIZE AT DOES ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
OF THIS MEASURE PLEASE
BRIEFING.
TO THE POINT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS JIM
WATER IN HER REPRESENTING GAINES
AND ASSOCIATES.
AND THE ALSO THOUGH FOLLOWING A
A GROUPS
THE BLACK BRANT GROUP THE
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN HUNTERS AND
STATE ARCHERY ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WILD
SHEEP.
THE TELL OR WETLANDS AND
WATERFOWL COUNCIL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA O. WILD
TURKEY FEDERATION.
AND THE ALSO USES AN ANECDOTE
FROM BEING A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA WATERFALL FOR OVER
NINE YEARS.
WHAT WE'VE FOUND IS THAT ONCE
YOU GET PEOPLE IN THE OUTDOORS
AND SEE HOW FANTASTIC IT IS?
YOU GET THEM HOOKED AND THIS
BILL IS A GREAT WAY TO DO IT.
THANK YOU.
LAURIE JACOBS WILL CALIFORNIA
HOUNDS ON FOR CONSERVATION WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION XENON I DO HAVE A
COLLEAGUE QUESTION.
THANK YOU CHAIR SO THE STATE IS
ABLE TO.
AUTHORIZED OR DESIGNATE THESE
DAYS DID YOU INQUIRE AS TO WHY
THEY HAVEN'T DONE THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND WELL. I WE DID AND THAT
THEY HAVE CONFIRMED THAT THEY
ARE IN A POSITION TO DO SO BUT I
KNOW THEY DIDN'T PROVIDE A
REASON.
AND.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE.
OR.
.
TESTIMONY INCLUDED THE COST OF
THE.
ORDER THE HOUSES THE COST OF
THAT THE LICENSE IN SAYING THAT
IT'S EXPENSIVE OR AMONG THE MOST
EXPENSIVE BUT WE ALSO HAVE. A
EXPENSES THAT WE TRY TO COVER.
UP IN THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
LICENSE FEES AND SO WE TRY TO
RECOUP WHAT THOSE ACTUAL COSTS
WOULD BE SO WHETHER IT'S
EXPENSIVE OR NOT WE HAVE ACTUAL
COST TO DO THE JOB OF DFW.
THAT YOU KNOW HELP SET WHAT
THAT HE WOULD BE RIGHT SO YOU
COULD SAY IT'S EXPENSIVE OR
ACTUALLY.
TRIES TO JUST RECOVER ARE REAL
COSTS
I THINK YOU'RE MAKING MY POINT
THAT I THAT THOSE OUT FUNDS ARE
NEEDED I TO FUND THESE EFFORTS
BY. THE INITIAL BARRIER TO
ENTRY.
KEEPS FOLKS OUT OF
PARTICIPATING BUT IF YOU PROVIDE
A MATCH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPERIENCE ARE THE SPORT.
WITHOUT HAVING TO INITIALLY PAY
THAT THE THAN YOU MIGHT END UP
BY GENERATING MUCH MORE REVENUE
SO WHY WOULD DFW DO THAT.
WELL IT'S UNCLEAR WE AT WE DID
ASK FOR AN EXPLANATION BUT YEAH
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN I THINK SIX
YEARS SINCE THEY ARE AUTHORIZED
TO DO SO IN AND IT HASN'T
HAPPENED SO THEY WANT
INCENTIVIZE BY MORE REVENUE TO.
CREATE THESE THREE DAYS.
IT'S AYE IT'S UNCLEAR YOU'D HAVE
TO ASK THEM.
THANK YOU.
AND YOUR QUESTION OR COMMENT
SEEN.
NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW SECOND BY MRS RUBIO.
WILL TAKE THAT AS YOUR. MAPS IT
TRIPS FOLLOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
GLORIA.
HARPER BUT HARPER AYE KALRA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE KNOW THE VIENEN
NO MATHIS.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
SOLIS AYE.
WOULD.
ALRIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT.
ITEM.
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ON.
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ.
OVER JOINING THE WILD TURKEY
FOUNDATION LETTERS.
I HAVE TO ASK LAYS.
ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING CHAIR I TRY
TO BE QUICK BECAUSE THEY MAY
HAVE SOME REALLY IMPORTANT KIDS
GO TALK TO. AB TWENTY.
ALRIGHT WE ARE TRYING TO FIX.
.
THE PROTEIN ISSUE IN OUR MPAS
BECAUSE THE FINE.
BASICALLY ALMOST
MAKE SET UP.
WORTH ITS COST TO VIOLATE SO I'D
GOTTEN WITNESSES WEARING A QUICK
ALRIGHT ZAKI POPPER ON THE
CONSERVATION DIRECTOR WHILE
COAST.
I'M HERE JOINED BY MY CO WORKER
COREY PICKING ANY CONSERVATION
COORDINATOR WHILE COAST. AND
WE'RE HERE THIS MORNING TO
REQUEST AYE VOTE FOR AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY NINE TO INCREASE THE
FINES FOR COMMERCIAL POACHING
VIOLATIONS. IN CALIFORNIA'S
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS OR MPAS.
WHILE BECAUSE IT'S AN
INTERNATIONAL TEAM THAT CONSERVE
COASTAL MARINE ECOSYSTEMS AND
WILDLIFE WE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
DEVELOPING CALIFORNIA'S MARINE
PROTECTED AREA NETWORK. AND THEN
WE TRANSITIONED INTO HELPING
IMPLEMENT THIS NETWORK THROUGH.
OUTREACH BUILDING PUBLIC
STEWARDSHIP CORNING CITIZEN
SCIENCE MONITORING AND ENHANCING
FOR SOME POLICY TO CALIFORNIA'S
A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THESE
UNDER WATER PARKS TWENTY THE
WORLD'S LARGEST NETWORK
INTEGRATED NETWORKS OF A MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS COVERS ABOUT
SIXTY PERCENT OF STATE WATERS.
GOALS INCREASING FISHERY BIOMASS
ENHANCING ECOSYSTEM HEALTH
ENHANCING RECREATIONAL VALUE OF
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST ICONIC
COASTAL PLACES.
ARE CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
OUR MPAS IS MAXIMUM PUBLIC
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REGULATIONS
THIS REQUIRES OUTREACH TO BROWN
DIVERSE PUBLIC AUDIENCE. ABOUT
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS IT
ALSO REQUIRES ADEQUATE
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS THAT ADDRESS
THE VARYING LEVELS OF MISS
COMPLIANCE ACROSS THE STATE. US
SO IN ADDITION TO THE OUTREACH
PROJECTS THAT WE UNDERTAKE WE
WORK WITH ENFORCEMENT ALLIED
AGENCIES PROSECUTORS FISHING
GROUPS MP A COLLABORATIVE
NETWORK AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER TO STRENGTHEN
MP ENFORCEMENT CALIFORNIA. AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH THE
SUCCESSFUL PASSING OF AB TWENTY.
TWO NINETY EIGHT A WHICH ROCAS
COSPONSORED MPA VIOLATIONS
BECAME SIDE OF ALL IS A
INFRACTION OR A MISDEMEANOR THIS
GREATLY IMPROVE THE ENFORCEMENT
OF LOWER LEVEL POACHING.
VIOLATIONS ACROSS THE STATE AS
INDICATED BY ENFORCEMENT AND
ALLIED AGENCIES NOW WORKING TO
ADD. TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF COMMERCIAL SCALE
POACHING CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A
HIT VERY VERY WELL EXPLAINED
YEAH THOROUGHLY.
AND DETAILED.
NEXT WEEK.
SO COURT BEGINNING WITH WILD
BECAUSE OF MOST FISHERMEN AND
BITTER WOMEN DO FOLLOW THE LAW.
AND A LAW ABIDING CITIZENS ARE
AFFECTED BY THE INCREASE
PENALTIES SET FORTH IN A
THE TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW PENALTIES
FOR POACHERS MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS ARE FOR AND FOR COMMERCIAL
ENTITIES ENTITIES.
INCLUDE OUR COMMERCIAL INCLUDING
COMMERCIAL PASSENGER FISHING
VESSELS OR PARTY BUT IS THERE
OTHER OTHERWISE KNOWN. ARE NOT
EFFECTIVE ECONOMIC DETERRENT
THESE PENALTIES VARY DEPENDING
ON THE EXACT VIOLATION BUT
GENERALLY UNDER FISHING GAME
CODE DON'T EXCEED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION. THESE LAW
OF LOW FINES CAN BE EASILY
ABSORBED BY BUSINESSES
AND WHEN THE CATCH OF SOME
SPECIES SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
SPINY LOBSTER CAN SELL FOR AS
MUCH AS THIRTY TWO DOLLARS A
POUND AT MARKET. APPROACHES CAN
CONTINUE TO PROFIT UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
IN CONTRAST PENALTIES FOR
ILLEGAL TROPHY HUNTING ANIMALS
LIKE A DEER AND ELK INCLUDE
FINES BETWEEN FIVE THOUSAND AND
FORTY THOUSAND AND UP TO YEAR
IMPRISONMENT COUNTY JAIL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE WOULD
ENHANCE REGULATIONS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER POACHING
FINES AND PENALTIES.
OUR IT WOULD CRACK DOWN ON
POACHING MPAS BY COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN AND PARTY BOATS BY
INCREASING PENALTIES.
FOR POACHING TO BE A SUFFICIENT
DETERRENT OF THIS BILLS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE OF OUR OCEANS
ARE STATEWIDE NETWORK OF MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS. AND WILL HELP
TO PROTECT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
INVESTED IN OUR OCEAN RESOURCES.
OUR MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE TOM RAFTER GO THE
SPORTFISHING CONSERVANCY AND WE
WORK WITH RECREATIONAL
FISHERMEN.
WE'VE DONE THINGS LIKE PCH
POACHERS CAN'T HIDE SHOWING YOU
ARE. WASTING.
INFORM WARDENS ON POACHERS AND
MORTON STAMPS.
IT'S IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
I GIVE. PROTECTION IS THE
IMPORTANT PART OF MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS. AND IT.
GOOD WALLS BUILD GOOD NEIGHBORS.
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
I DON'T KNOW. ALL THE NEIGHBORS
OKAY.
IN THIS CONTEXT MAY BE.
NOW WE HAVE A. FEW FOLKS LINED
UP. HEADING RIGHT ON THE HEAD
TO.
HEAR CUT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NAY
DISSOCIATES FOR THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM AND FOR THE RESOURCES
LEGACY FUND.
JUST MULLIN FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
ALSO OFFICE BY DEFENDANTS WANT
LIKE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE CITY OF
ITS AND IT IS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MANUAL WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEE NO ONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW SECOND BY MRS
RUBIO. NEAR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
BIGELOW.
THANK YOU.
AS
CLEARLY I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL YEAH I'M I DO WANNA HAVE I
DO HAVE AN AREA OF CONCERN. YOU
KNOW WITH RESPECT TO THE.
THE OPERATORS OF CERTAIN BOATS.
MAY NOT BE AWARE OF WHAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES ARE DOING FROM TIME TO
TIME.
AND SO THE CAPTAIN OR THE OWNER
OF THE VESSEL MAY OUT.
THE PUTTING THESE PEOPLE OUT
THERE AND THEY MAY BE.
DOING THIS.
.
RIGHT WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE IS
OUR WAY THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH
RESOLVING THAT WE CAN YOUR THE
TERMS OF YOUR BILL YET WERE
ABSOLUTELY.
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE THE RIGHT FOR
PARTIES HELP LIABLE EXACTLY. YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY IF IT CONTINUES
TO HAPPEN TO A BOAT OWNER WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT AND
THEY'RE LIABLE POLITICALLY WITH
YEAH I THOUGHT GALLAGHER. YOU
KNOW ONCE OR TWICE A SLAP ON THE
HAND THAT IMMEDIATELY YOU NEED A
DIFFERENT OPERATOR THEM EXACTLY
EXACTLY WHAT IT WILL BE WORKING
ON IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
SEE I.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE. GLORIA.
HARPER. HARPER NO. KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO ARE RUBIO AYE SOLACE
SOLIS TYPE WOULD. WOULD I.
NGUYEN.
THANK YOU. OF I WILL KEEP THAT
THE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS HAD
ON SOME FRIEDMAN.
BETTER.
SIMPLE BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION.
.
SO.
THERE IS A MOTION ON THAT
REMAINS BUILT BY.
MORE WORK SECOND BY SOME MEMBERS
STONE.
SO WE.
SHE'D DO HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
AYE RECOMMENDATION YOU KNOW
MOTIONS SECOND ON YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HAPPY TO GIVE AS LONG OR AS
SHORT A PRESENTATION AS YOU'D
LIKE THIS BILL WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT WATER METERS THAT ARE SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE SOME BASIC
LEVEL OF ACCURACY.
BUILT INTO THEM AS WELL IS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT OVER TIME THEY
ARE ACCURATE.
COMMONSENSE BILL THAT WOULD LIKE
TO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS ED O. ST I'M ON THE
STAFF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL.
AND WE THANK A ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR HER INTEREST AND
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THIS
WOULD DEAL WITH TWO ASPECTS OF
WATER METERS THERE SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT BUT THEY'RE BOTH
EQUALLY IMPORTANT. PART OF IT IS
THE ACCURACY OF METERS WHEN
THEY'RE NEW. AND THE BILL WOULD
DIRECT THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
SET STANDARDS FOR THE ACCURACY
OF NEWLY PURCHASED METERS.
THE OTHER ASPECT IS THE ACCURACY
OF METERS THAT ARE INSTALLED IN
CURRENTLY IN SERVICE.
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE NOW ALL URBAN
WATER SUPPLIERS ARE REQUIRED TO.
A PREPARE AND SUBMIT TO THE
STATE A WATER LOSS AUDIT ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
AND HAVING AND ASSESSMENT OF THE
DEGREE OF ACCURACY OR INACCURACY
OF THE METERS UTTERANCE SERVICE.
IS REALLY ESSENTIAL PART OF
GETTING A GOOD ESTIMATE OF WATER
LOSSES FROM SYSTEM.
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FEATURE
THE BILL IT WOULD DIRECT THE
STATE BOARD TO SET A CRITERIA
FOR MAKING STATISTICALLY SOUND
ESTIMATES OF WATER METER
ACCURACY
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR.
THE MEASURE.
SEE NO ONE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS. COMMENTS
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AGAIN BY MISTER WOOD SECOND
WEBMASTERS.
LIVING.
.
CHUCK CLOSE JUST ANYBODY THAT'S
SEEN IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
ARGUMENTS ABOUT ACCURACY OF
WATER METERING FOR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS KNOWS THAT THIS IS A
LONG TIME COMING THANK YOU WILL
LAST FOR ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHIU ARE
CHU AYE. FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA.
HARPER.
HARPER NO KALRA.
COLOR AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
MATHIS RUBIO.
SOLACE
SOLIS I WOULD.
WOULD I.
LEAVE THE DOOR OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS I'D LIKE YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU UP. COLLEAGUES A A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR THE STABLE
GROUND MANAGEMENT.
WATER MANAGEMENT
BILL THAT UP FOCUSES ON THE SAN
LUIS REY VALLEY GROUNDWATER
BASIN.
I JUST THE BASIN DESIGNATIONS
WITHIN THE SAN LUIS REY
GROUNDWATER BASE IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT.
SO THIS BILL IS TO LINE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ISSUES SIGMA. FEDERAL
TRAVEL WATER RIGHTS AND
DOWNSTREAM WATER RIGHTS TO ALLOW
THE FULLEST PARTICIPATION OF THE
OVERLYING USERS. OF THE SAN LUIS
REY GROUNDWATER BASIN WITH ME IS
A JOINT AUTHORED SOME MEMBER
WALDRON WHO WILL READ A
STATEMENT AS WELL.
THE MOTION FROM MISTER SOLACE A
SECOND FROM MISTER HARPER PLEASE
MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF AB FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR WHICH DIRECTLY
IMPACTS MY DISTRICT.
THIS MEASURE WILL GO WRONG A
LONG WAY TO HELPING LOCAL TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN MY DISTRICT AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WILL PROTECT
GROUND WATER RIGHTS UP AND DOWN
THE ST LOUIS WAY GROUNDWATER
BASIN. I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
OF THE WATER AGENCIES THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE COMMITTEE.
THAT YOU'VE DEDICATED TO THIS
BILL AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
MR HUMANNESS.
THANK YOU MY NAME AND BONE WAS
EDDIE I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN LUIS REY INDIAN WATER
AUTHORITY.
THE OLDEST OF THE.
CONGRESSIONALLY CHARTERED UNION
MODERATE FORTY AND THE UNITED
STATES.
CONSISTING OF FIVE TRIBES.
SAP WHICH WILL BRING COLIN
POWELL LOMBARDIA APARTMENT
TRIBES.
WITHIN SICK MOTHER THE
DESIGNATION CALL SUBTERRANEAN
STREAM.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THERE IS NO DESIGNATION BETWEEN
SURPLUS WATER AND GROUNDWATER.
SUBTERRANEAN STREAMS
DESIGNATION.
THEN REQUIRES THAT ANOTHER
AGENCY HAVE CONTROL.
ABOUT WE JUST FINISHED UP
ANOTHER JOB OVER THE THE
GROUNDWATER.
THE WE JUST FINISHED UP A FIFTY
YEAR OR YOUR WHOLE LAWSUIT CALL
SAN LUIS REY HIM IN WATER
SETTLEMENT.
BOB PASTOR MAY SEVENTEENTH THE
LAST YEAR.
OF PART OF THE REQUIREMENT OF
THAT LITIGATION WAS THAT WE THE
UPPER TRIBES.
PROVIDED GET WATERED DOWN TO
PAULA WHICH IS A.
MOST OF THE LOWER AREA AND THE
SUN WAS RATE BASED ON.
ALL UNDER SIGNAL LAW.
BEFORE YOU GET TO THE PAUL
RESERVATION THAT TURNS IT INTO A
SUBTERRANEAN STREAM. DESIGNATION
WHICH TAKES THAT.
OUT OF THE JURISDICTION OF THE
EXISTING SALAS TRADE BASEMAN.
I PUT THAT ON THE JURISDICTION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF LOW OF
WATER ROUTE RESOURCES.
INSTEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THE OTHER DAY W. OUR WATER
RESOURCES.
WATER CONTROL BOARDS COULD BE
THE OTHER THE OTHER WITNESS I
GET ALL THESE ACRONYMS BUT BUT.
YEAH WE WORK WITH BOTH AGENCIES
TO WORK WITH.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE FIVE.
TRIBAL RESERVATIONS. ON THE
RIVER. UNDER FEDERAL LAW. YOU
HAVE STATE LAW INVOLVED THAT THE
VOLVO ALL OF THE FOLKS IN THE
REST OF THE YEAR THE BASED ON.
ALL THE WAY DOWN THE CITY OF
OCEANSIDE OTHER WORDS ENTIRE
LINK.
THE FINAL THREE REVERSES
AFFECTED.
AND WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS
TWO THINGS ONE IT'LL TAKE THE
DESIGNATION OF SUBTERRANEAN
STREAMS. UNTREATED AND
GROUNDWATER.
IT ALSO CREATED AN UPPER SEVERAL
TRADE BASIN AND LOWER.
SEVERAL TRADE BASIN.
SO WHAT UNIQUE ABOUT THIS ALL OF
THE USERS WITH EXCEPTION OF ONE
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE. FROM THE
VERY VERY BEGINNING OF THE SAN
LUIS REY RIVER.
TWO WORK COMES OUT OF THE CITY
OF OCEANSIDE WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT ON THIS BILL.
FOR THERE THERE'S ONE SMALL
GROUP CALL THE OF SOME OF THREE
MUNICIPAL WATER. COMPANY WHICH
IS IT BASICALLY A FAMILY.
A LITTLE ON THE SMALL AREA.
ALTHOUGH THEY DON'T ONLY ONE
THAT I KNOW THAT ARE OPPOSED. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND.
THE WHOLE RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
OTHER NET
ASH BUT I NAME IS RON WATKINS
AND NO.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
VALUING OF MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT WHICH IS THE. LARGEST
WATER SUPPLIER IN THE.
IN THOSE CHANDLER A BASIN HEARD.
AND I'M ALSO ON THE BOARD OF THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY.
AND AND THE.
WE ARE ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE US AND.
WATER USE.
THE LIFE BLOOD.
THERE'S SAM WORRY ABOUT BALLOT
IN ALL ASPECTS OF IT.
AND WE'VE WE'VE USE SIGMA.
NOT OBSERVE A NEW BURDEN.
BUT AS AN OPPORTUNITY.
DEVELOP.
A WATER PLAN.
SUSTAINABLE WATER PLAN
GOING OUT INTO THE FUTURE.
WELL NOT JUST WITH GROUND WATER
BUT IMPORTED WATER IN SURFACE
WATER.
AND WHILE.
HOW SO? WE ARE.
BUT WE RUSSIA HAVE RECOGNIZED
FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
VICTOR TRIED.
BE A PARTICIPANT IN THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
FEDERAL WATER RIGHTS
A GROUND WATER RIGHTS THEY HAVE
RIGHTS TO IMPORTED WATER.
AND SURFACE WATER. AND GO AND
THE TRIBES AROMA HAVE VERY
RESPONSIBLY.
STEPPED FORWARD.
AND AND SHOULD YES THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE HOME WITH US EVEN
THOUGH. THEY COULD BE EXEMPT
UNDER SIGMA.
BUT THEY YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE WITH US.
ALSO I THINK YOU AND YOUR IN
SUPPORT.
YES THANK HIM.
THANK YOU.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S GLENFERRIE ALL SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY. OR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BUT
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED.
PROVISION THAT WOULD HELP
IMPROVE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT GROUNDWORK
SUSTAINABILITY IN THIS
PARTICULAR REGION.
GOOD DAY. BOBBIE WATSON A PERSON
LOUIS RATE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT WERE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN AND DONE.
.
ZERO MOTION.
WE ARE YOU THAT WE DID SOLACE
AND THEN OUR YEAH THANK YOU OKAY
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
SCENE.
NONE MISTER.
GARCIA WAS A NECKLACE FOR YOUR.
GREAT ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU AS
YOU NOTED YOUR TAKING THE.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT SEND
YOUR RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED SO I THINK YOU FOR
THAT ALSO JUST THINK THAT THIS
BILL AND I MISTER IS THAT HIS
TESTIMONY REALLY REFLECTS ON. A
LITTLE BIT HOW COMPLICATED EVEN
CONVOLUTED AND RUSHED THE SIGMA.
RA LAWS WERE AS THEY WERE PASS
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST OF MANY
BILLS THAT HAVE COME TO TRY TO
PUT SOME SENSE INTO IT TO HELP
LOCAL COMMUNITIES DEAL. WITH
THIS AND SO I SAY THANK YOU TO
MISS WALDRON MISTER GARCIA
MISTER ROSETTI FOR WORKING ON
THIS AND HAVE IT MAKE SENSE FOR
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
ITS CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA BY
SEE I. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHIU ACT CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
HARPER. HARPER AYE COLOR. COLOR
AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD. WOULD I.
THE BILL IS OUT TEN SEP AND WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU
.
I WOULD HAVE A FEW A.
BILL STILL UP ON CALL FOR ADD ON
SAYS WHO MADAM CLERK I GUESS IS
CALLED THE.
THOSE BILLS.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CARILLO.
CARILLO I.
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE.
HARPER.
HARPER I.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE I
WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING
.
OKAY LET BILL IS OUT ON A
FOURTEEN ZERO ABOVE.
WE'LL KEEP THAT HAVE OKAY WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
AB NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. DO
PASSES MENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW.
CHOI.
GLORIA.
MATHIS
RUBIO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON ABC NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY FIVE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CARILLO.
REAL AYE CHOI.
GLORIA.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I HARPER BUT I HARPER
AYE KALRA. KALRA I WOULD.
WOULD I.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
I.
GALLAGHER I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHIU ARE.
CHIU I.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
EDUARDO GARCIA. GALLAGHER NO
GALLAGHER NO.
KALRA.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
CARILLO.
KALRA AYE.
SOLIS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SOLACE I WOULD. WOULD I.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CARILLO.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT.
CARILLO I.
CHOI.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN CARILLO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN. AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
GLORIA AYE AYE GLORIA AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD.
WOULD I.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTIES MOTION
AS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER AYE CARILLO. CARILLO
AYE CHOI.
CHIU.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING.
DID.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVEN DE VOTE
CHANGE WOULD NOT.
.
WOULD KNOW.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CARILLO.
TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE.
BIGELOW.
I.
CARILLO AYE. GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD.
WOULD I.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I HARPER.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE RUBIO.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
HARPER I.
AB THIRTY TWO A SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER NO.
BIGELOW.
CARILLO.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB THIRTY
TWO A SIX FRIEDMAN.
CARILLO I.
CHOI.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE. MATHIS.
RUBIO.
NINE.
LOS.
VOTED.
HE WROTE A.
YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT WILL THE DRIFTING?
SAID.
HI.
STRONG MAGNETIC.
PEOPLE LOVE YOU. THAT'S ABOUT.
NINE SEVENTEEN SIX.
THE CITY.
BUT.
THE HONEY THREE THOUSAND ONE.
COLLEGE.
YEAH I APOLOGIZE A NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO HARPER
VOTE CHANGE NOT VOTING.
ZERO.
AND I HAVE A NINE.
THE NINETEEN.
AB NINETEEN FORTY FOUR CHOI.
YES.
CHOI AYE.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHOI YEAH I.
BY THE WAY.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN NINE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY CHOI YES
CHOI AYE ON.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB THIRTY
TWO OH SIX TROY.
TROY NO.
NINE.
WALDRON ITEM NUMBER TWELVE MONTH
TWENTY EIGHT FIVE.
THAT NIGHT.
BUT I.
YES IT.
OF THE.
THAT.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
CONSENT CALENDAR. I'VE.
GLORIA
.
THERE'S A
THE.
I COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED